certes que des cotisations familles mais
tout de même d'une partie exonération ça
fait quoi aussi à ce qui avait été
décidé au Père FSH je me rappelle sur
les médecins qu'on allait inciter à
continuer leur activité mais on les
exonération exonérantes cotisation
sociale alors ces exonérations n'ont pas
de sens le travail produit de la
cotisation il faut maintenir ses
cotisations qui financent notre système
de protection sociale donc sauf avoir
une idéologie de l'exonération quoi
qu'il en coûte et bien si on défend un
système juste répartition fondée sur la
cotisation il faut maintenir pour tous
ceux qui sont éligibles à ce contrat
l'ensemble des cotisations sociales
c'est l'objet de cet amendement je vous
remercie monsieur le Président est-ce
que je considère que l'ensemble des sous
amendements présentés par le groupe
socialiste ont été défendus madame Lubin
non
[Musique]
44 le 44
depuis un moment
excusez-moi monsieur le président
non je défends le 44 oui on est d'accord
me perturber pas derrière oui cet
amendement il vise à supprimer les
alinéas 11 et 12 parce que en fait il
porte sur les allocations familiales et
c'est quand même un sujet qui
régulièrement revient de manière feutrée
ou incidente dans nos débats à la
commission des affaires sociales mais
aussi dans d'autres débats quelle
politique familiale il se trouve que je
considère que la question démographiques
sont des vrais sujets d'ailleurs je n'ai
toujours pas compris quelle est la
politique démographique de ce
gouvernement ni à la gare de la Daniel
hegarde la transition démographique
c'est-à-dire l'augmentation du nombre de
personnes âgées ni d'ailleurs à l'égard
de la politique familiale et qu'elle est
aujourd'hui ce que ce gouvernement veut
offrir proposer aux familles à toutes
les familles de façon à ce que les
conditions d'accueil des jeunes enfants
soit les meilleurs or il y a là petite
ambiguïté voire même une contradiction
pour moi vous êtes souvent mes chers
collègues de droite très offensifs sur
les allocations familiales sur la
politique nataliste n'est pas exactement
mon sujet et sur les moyens que nous
devons y consacrer et pour cela
vous êtes prêt malgré cela vous êtes
prêt à supprimer pour le contrat dernier
embauche une part des cotisations
allocations familiales qui pèse
aujourd'hui sont les employeurs donc je
vous appelle simplement par cet
amendement avec mes collègues à être
cohérent entre d'une part votre vision
de la politique familiale et d'autre
part votre vision des moyens de croître
l'emploi des seniors merci alors nous
allons demander l'avis de la commission
sur l'ensemble des sous amendements
c'est le rapporteur
oui merci monsieur le Président j'ai
deux minutes par sous amendement je suis
pas obligé de les utiliser rassurez-vous
monsieur mais ça nécessite quand même
des précisions un nous avons pas parlé
du coup pas d'histoire d'argent monsieur
le ministre entre nous cependant il y a
des répercussions effectivement et vous
avez annoncé à ce titre là un coup de
800 millions d'euros qu'aurait ce
contrat là parce que vous pensez que il
y aura un effet d'aubaine et que les
employeurs vont pas discerner la
différence entre le CDI classique et le
CDI senior qui est différent alors
effectivement on arrive et je confirme
je confirme c'est c'est 800 millions
d'euros mais je pense que le CDI senior
c'est autre chose et s'il y a des
exonérations on peut les estimer plus on
les estime ses exonérations de façon
importante plus plus le bénéfice est
important pour l'ensemble de la société
car si on fait des exonérations à un
coup de poids inutile ça veut dire que
derrière
les cotisations familiales s'entrent 30
et 5 entre 3 et 5% sur 40% de
cotisations salariale et patronales donc
si vous perdez pour le budget de l'État
ou de la sécurité sociale 3 à 5 % et que
vous gagnez 40 - 3 5 35 à 37 %, c'est
tout bénef et pendant que votre Seigneur
est employé dans un cadre particulier de
ce CDI senior avec un accompagnement et
bien il n'est pas au chômage et le
chômage on sait que ça coûte cher donc
l'intérêt pour la société pour les
comptes de l'État pour les contes de la
sécurité sociale c'est que ce dispositif
enfin marche parce qu'on en a déjà
essayé beaucoup et ça n'a pas toujours
marché il n'empêche que si nous avons
une vision différente contre l'emploi
des seniors il faut se douter d'outils
nouveaux donc je lance effectivement
cette piste là et c'est les partenaires
sociaux qui vont définir par branche
quels sont les branches intéressées si
débranches ne sont pas intéressées et
bien il y a pas de voilà si des branches
sont intéressées et bien elle
définissent qu'elle doit être les
conditions de négociation entre le
salariale employeur quant à cet
accompagnement jusqu'à l'âge légal et
c'est comme les contrats chantiers quand
vous construisez un collège et il y a
des présidents de départements qui sont
là quand vous le construisez construisez
un collège ça dure entre 3 5 7 ans
parfois plus et en conséquence quand
vous embauchez des personnes vous prenez
un CDI chantier de la durée du chantier
là c'est la durée de la fin de carrière
merci monsieur le Président mais je
tenais à présenter ces précisions
maintenant je réponds sous amendements
parce que c'est tout à fait important
madame Lubin propose
d'appeler ça contrat de dernier embauche
je crois qu'on aille mis un avis
défavorable à la commission mais
franchement si ça peut nous réunir qu'on
l'appelle contraignant ou dernier
embauche ça correspond à ça ça peut être
l'intitulé de dernier en box donc là
aussi les partenaires sociaux définiront
la façon dont ils veulent l'appeler
franchement j'ai aucun état d'âme
là-dessus mais ça rejoint notre
préoccupation parce que c'est celle que
nous avions définies lors du rapport que
nous avions fait sur l'emploi des
seniors donc c'est tout à fait important
en ce qui concerne Olivier et nos
Olivier Hainaut nous propose
effectivement de déterminer un âge
différent alors déjà monsieur le
ministre des comptes sociaux et des
comptes de l'État nous disent que ça
coûte cher à 60 ans Alors j'ai pas osé
franchement
envisagé qu'on puisse le mettre à partir
de 55 ans bien entendu ce seront des
partenaires sociaux qui selon les
branches nous dirons quel âge il faut
mettre voyez ça n'a justement c'est pas
d'ici de niveau du Parlement qu'on va
définir tout cela on a véritablement une
négociation qui peut s'instaurer par
branche et peut-être que on peut
comprendre que c'est un âge différent
selon le type de métier à mesure la
pénibilité on aura l'occasion de le
définir c'est la raison pour laquelle
j'ai mis un avis défavorable en ce qui
concerne effectivement
je crois que c'est
je ne sais plus qui excusez-moi non
c'est aussi Monique Monique Rubin
jusque 70 ans oui 70 ans c'est le seuil
c'est toi je crois 70 ans c'est le seuil
actuel
d'emploi où on peut effectivement
définir une rupture
unilatérale demandée par l'employeur
pour mise à la retraite avec des
conditions bien spécifiques en ce qui
concerne les cotisations le forfait
social qui est adapté à ce type de
prestation avant 70 ans si l'employeur
ne souhaite rompre avec son employé sa
dispositif de licenciement classique ou
une rupture conventionnelle
c'est un frein il faut bien reconnaître
aujourd'hui savoir quand vous avez des
seniors qui peuvent rester jusqu'à 70
ans parce que ça dépend du salarié quand
il peut partir à la retraite il prévient
je pars à la retraite sauf que s'il ne
veut pas partir à la traite
effectivement nombre d'entreprises nous
disent on est contraint de par la loi de
les garder jusqu'à 70 ans et en
conséquence en conséquence ça peut poser
un problème quand vous embauchez un
seigneur vers 60 60 ans
ça fera l'emploi et beaucoup
d'entreprises
hésitent parce que
voyez-vous on peut comprendre que donc
c'est la raison pour laquelle il faut un
contrat spécifique incitatif pourront se
fera à l'emploi parce que compte tenu de
la longévité il faut vraiment qu'il y
ait cette prise de conscience et pour
que elle soit véritablement collective
et ben donnons des outils pour aider à
prendre conscience que les seniors ça va
effectivement contenu de la longévidée
peut-être travailler un peu plus
longtemps en tout cas il faut que ça
puisse être ainsi si on veut éviter de
les mettre dans le dispositif chômage et
trop souvent de la précarité en ce qui
concerne les exonérations
pour lequel on a eu deux remarques
particulières oui nous sommes pas fans
des exonérations et mais cependant
cependant cependant
exonération familiale la branche famille
Laurence Rossignol oui
nous voulons et nous allons l'affirmer à
travers la surcotisation que nous
proposerons pour les maires de famille
qui ont une majoration dès l'instant où
elles ont eu l'âge du taux plein avant
un ange légal etc donc cette majoration
nous dit non mais c'est la contrainte
d'un PLFSS si je propose moi je vais
proposer à titre personnel une
exonération chômage ça me paraît
tellement logique puisque vous avez un
contrat qui fait que vous engagez de
garder jusqu'à la retraite votre salarié
donc il n'ira pas dans la cage chômage
en conséquence ce serait légitime c'est
une exonération de la cotisation chômage
là aussi c'est les partenaires sociaux
qui vont le dire ou à travers une loi
travail que vous pourrez lui proposer on
ne peut pas dans le cas du PLFSS puisque
je vous rappelle mais vous le savez bien
vous tous que les contes lunédiques ne
rentrent pas dans le cas du pérfss
contrairement à ce que nous
contrairement merci madame la Présidente
contrairement à ce que nous demandions
rappelez-vous nous pensions que nous
pourrions avoir un regard voyez ça nous
aurait permis de voir les choses un
petit peu différemment mais les
exonérations mes chers collègues
on peut se les permettre quand on a une
assiette assez importante pour les
cotisations la France ne produit pas
assez c'est bien notre difficulté c'est
pour ça que nous avons une base annonce
commerciale négative il faut élargir la
base de cotisations et cette réforme va
dans ce sens-là et à ce moment-là si
vous avez élargi votre base de
cotisation les exonérations prennent une
dimension tout à fait différente
je pense avoir répondu à toutes les
interrogations qui a été traduite à
travers tous ces amendements merci alors
la vie du gouvernement à la fois sur
l'amendement de Monsieur Savary
au nom de la commission sociale
et puis sur les sous amendements merci
monsieur le président madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales Monsieur et Madame et Monsieur
les rapporteurs mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs nous sommes venus à deux
avec mon collègue miséricorde publique
pour tenter de résister aux Astro de
monsieur le rapporteur et de la
commission des affaires sociales donc si
vous voulez bien monsieur le Président
je répondrai sur les aspects qui
relèvent du code du travail et peut-être
que mon collègue pourrait répondre sur
la partie du coup éclairer l'assemblée
concernant ce contrat nous avons à ce
stade trois interrogations deux attentes
et une crainte que je partage avec vous
les trois interrogations quant à la mise
en oeuvre du contrat proposé par la
Commission des affaires sociales
concerne d'une part le principe
d'égalité avec la difficulté lorsqu'on
crée des bornes d'âge sur l'accès à un
contrat de travail d'une nature
spécifique le risque qu'il y ait des
effets de seuil des effets d'aubaine et
des effets de distorsion la deuxième
interrogation concerne
le ciblage de cet outil et nous
souhaiterions voir s'il est possible
d'aller vers un ciblage en termes de
bénéficiaires concernant plutôt les
demandeurs d'emploi que l'ensemble des
seniors pour éviter prévenir toute forme
d'effets d'aubaines et puis évidemment
nous souhaitons puisque j'ai évoqué ce
terme d'effet de Ben veillez à ce que la
différence entre le CDI droit commun et
ce nouvel outil qui pourrait s'adresser
au Seigneur soit une différence
particulièrement marquée je donne bien
volontiers actes sur le rapporteur d'un
certain nombre de discussions de
modifications notamment dans la
rédaction de l'amendement pour envoyer
une concertation avec les partenaires
sociaux puisque nous considérons et
c'est là l'occasion pour moi de venir
sur les deux points qui sont des
attentes que le gouvernement exprime à
cette occasion nous considérons qu'il y
aurait d'une part un intérêt à ce que
cette mesure soit créée de nature avec
nature dans un premier temps
expérimental et d'autre part nous
considérons que ce CDI propre senior
relève d'un article que monsieur le
Président du Sénat connaît bien
l'article la partie dite L1 du code du
travail travail et qui cela doit
renvoyer à une constatation
interprofessionnelle là où nous avons
encore un écart dans la rédaction la
préparation de ce dispositif avec
monsieur le rapporteur c'est que le
gouvernement considère qu'il y aurait
lieu de renvoyer la totalité des
paramètres et de la définition du
nouveau contrat un décret faisant suite
à une concertation interprofessionnelle
alors que la rédaction de l'amendement
prévoit à ce stade une écriture plus
précise sans toutefois exonérer le
gouvernement d'une obligation de
concertation interprofessionnelle selon
ce sont là les trois points que je
voulais souligner d'une part des
interrogations d'autre part le fait que
nous donnons bien évidemment acte à
Monsieur rapporteur et la commission
qu'un certain nombre de modifications
allant dans le bon sens sont déjà
intervenus et enfin deux points
d'attente sur le caractère expérimental
et sur l'articulation avec le L1 du Code
du travail que je voulais souligner je
le fais monsieur le Président en ayant
bien en tête et Monsieur rapporteur que
lorsque l'article du Code du travail
concernant l'obligation de concertation
interprofessionnelle
a été intégré au code du travail je
crois en 2003 ou 2004 2004 il me semble
sous votre autorité il avait été
explicitement prévu que cette obligation
de concertation interprofessionnelle ne
concernait ni les propositions de loi ni
les amendements je crois que l'esprit et
je crois aussi que c'est partagé que
l'esprit prévaut et que il est utile
d'avoir une concertation
interprofessionnelle sur ces sujets-là
voilà les remarques qui m'amènent à dire
qu'à à ce stade et en fonction de la
rédaction qui est proposée à cet instant
au Sénat la vie du gouvernement ne peut
pas être favorable et donc par
conséquent il est il est défavorable
mais avec l'espoir que les discussions
et je l'espère les débats que nous
aurons encore cette semaine et ensuite
dans la perspective de la prolongation
du débat parlementaire autour de ce
texte nous puissions trouver un terrain
d'entente
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les sénatrices et sénateur moi
je vous remercie de mettre ce sujet là
sur la table puisque je crois qu'on
cherche tous à réduire le chômage chez
les seniors et à ce titre c'est toujours
intéressant évidemment de discuter des
pistes qui sont proposées moi je suis
toujours assez sceptique sur des
propositions d'allègement de cotisation
ciblées sur un âge donné aujourd'hui il
n'y a pas d'allaagement de cotisations
liées à un âge il y a des allègements de
cotisations qui sont liés à un type de
contrats qui sont liés à une
rémunération non les jeunes monsieur
Husson on parle d'allègement sur les
jeunes parce que il y a des allègements
qui sont ciblés sur les niveaux de
salaire au SMIC et que c'est
principalement des jeunes qui sont au
SMIC mais vous n'avez pas de vous n'avez
pas d'allaagement de cotisation lié à un
âge pour une bonne raison à mon avis
c'est que le risque c'est qu'il y a des
effets de seuil
vous dites il y a un allègement de
cotisation pour l'employeur à partir de
60 ans qu'est-ce qui va se passer pour
les gens qui ont 58 59 ans qui se
présentent dans une entreprise pour être
recruté on va leur dire vous ne coûtez
plus cher que ce que vous me coûterez à
60 ans donc attendez attendez un an ou
deux ans revenez me voir dans un an ou
dans deux ans quand j'aurai droit à une
exonération de cotisation parce que vous
avez plus de 60 ans donc le risque c'est
qu'on décale le problème et que c'est
que des personnes qui aujourd'hui en
plus 60 ans et sont au chômage en fait
on décale le problème à ceux qui sont
juste avant 60 ans parce que eux
n'auront pas droit à l'exonération pour
leur employeur s'ils sont recrutés ça
c'est la première chose sur la deuxième
chose c'est un amendement qui coûte
effectivement
une certaine somme le chiffre de 800
millions d'euros c'est 800 millions
d'euros si les recrutements actuels
au-delà de 60 ans se font avec le CDI
senior on parle des faits d'auben c'est
à dire que aujourd'hui vous avez
aujourd'hui vous avez en moyenne 100 000
CDI qui sont signés pour des personnes
qui ont plus de 60 ans par an
si désormais tous ces CDI signés pour
des personnes qui ont plus de 60 ans
chaque année sont faits avec le nouveau
contrat bah non bah en même temps vous
prenez à la vous mettez à la place d'un
employeur vous dites il y a un nouveau
contrat CDI senior qui existe avec moins
de cotisations il va plutôt choisir
celui-là aujourd'hui vous avez 100 000
personnes qui sont recrutées en CDI
après 60 ans si désormais ils sont tous
recrutés avec ce nouveau CDI ça coûte
800 millions d'euros pour la branche
famille et ça veut dire que la branche
famille se retrouve déficitaire dès
l'année 2025 or j'entends sur tous les
bancs une volonté d'avoir une politique
familiale ambitieuse pour notamment
inciter à la natalité dans notre pays je
rejoins cet objectif mais donc là on se
retrouve à dépouiller la branche famille
si on va encore plus loin sur l'effet
d'aubaine ça veut dire si toutes les
personnes qui sont actuellement en
emploi en CDI de plus de 60 ans
l'employeur se dit bah en fait j'ai un
allègement de cotisation si je change de
CDI donc on va toutes les basculer en
CDI seniors là ça coûte 2 milliards 300
millions d'euros je dis pas qu'on ira
jusque là monsieur le rapporteur
évidemment
mais en tout cas ça veut dire que si
toutes les personnes qui sont
aujourd'hui en CDI au-delà de 60 ans
elles sont basculées dans un contrat CDI
seniors
ça ferait ça ferait ce coup-là j'entends
que vous souhaitez et notamment dans la
discussion avec les partenaires sociaux
qui est des garde-fous pour qu'ils
puissent pas y avoir tous ses effets
d'aubaine mais en tout cas le fêter que
sur les 100000 recrutements qui a chaque
année après 60 ans s'ils sont tous
recrutés au CDI senior et encore une
fois vous mettez à la place de
l'employeur il y a une baisse de
cotisation la plutôt le faire deuxième
chose deuxième chose c'est un dispositif
qui va plutôt favoriser les hauts
revenus les eaux salaires ceux pour les
CE pour qui la question des cotisations
n'est pas l'élément déterminant pour les
employeurs si je vous donne quelques
chiffres pour un salarié qui a un une
rémunération de 4500 euros aujourd'hui
vous aurez un effet maximal de baisse de
cotisation alors même que pour un senior
qui a une rémunération autour de 2000
2500 euros il y a déjà des allègements
de cotisation notamment avec le bandeau
famille et donc l'effet incitatif serait
le plus fort pour des salariés qui ont
les plus hautes rémunérations pour
lesquelles a priori l'incitation sur les
cotisations n'est pas l'élément
déterminant pour leur recrutement donc
c'est au moins 800 millions d'euros de
coûts pour des salariés et des seniors
dont a priori il y a pas le son pour
lesquels il y a le plus besoin d'un
effet incitatif sur les cotisations donc
moi encore une fois j'arrête sur ce
sujet là il y a des dispositifs un peu
semblables qui ont été testés au niveau
européen et un rapport très intéressant
de France stratégie de 2017 qui dit que
ces dispositifs d'exonération
d'allègement de cotisations ciblées sur
les seniors dans les pays qui l'ont
essayé c'est à dire la Finlande la Suède
et la Hongrie se sont révélés
inefficaces à la fois sur les
recrutements et sur les salaires donc
encore une fois on partage tous le même
objectif moi vous le savez j'ai pas de
tabou sur les allègements de cotisation
les baisses de cotisation je pense que
quand c'est
ça vous le savez non mais vous le savez
donc ça donc ça rend donc ça rend ma
position ça rend ma position d'autant
plus forte et objective moi je pense que
oui oui il y a des exonérations et des
allègements qui sont utiles mais il faut
qu'on soit sûr de leur efficacité en
l'occurrence là je crée un effet
d'aubaine qui met notre branche famille
dans le rouge donc pour ces raisons
défavorables
merci alors nous allons commencer
mille excuses de rallonger un peu le
débat mais je préfère répondre je répète
je préférerais répondre tout de suite à
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
ministre
je ne crois pas que vous n'avez pas
compris le dispositif je pense que vous
avez la posture du gardien du temple ce
que je comprends bien du temple
financier je le comprends bien non non
il est pas question que les CDI de 60
ans soient tous pris en compte dans ce
dispositif il est question de proposer
une alternative d'où l'intérêt des
branches de définir dans les branches
l'intérêt de ce CDI non jusqu'à présent
dans les CDI on discute pas d'histoire
d'âge avec avec le salarié tandis que là
ça veut dire que il y a un aspect très
confidentiel jusqu'à présent où le
salarié expose ses conditions de
retraite on regarde sur un faux retraite
les conditions c'est comme un contrat de
chantier donc ça veut dire que par
rapport à ces exonérations de tous les
emplois de 60 ans vous auriez
vous auriez
une embauche supplémentaire de seniors
c'est la raison pour laquelle ça mérite
d'exister alors maintenant vous parlez
d'histoire de bornage pas de bandage moi
je suis mais alors à 100% d'accord avec
vous mais 100% mais pourquoi pourquoi
dans l'article suivant vous nous
proposez des bornes d'âge pour les
carrières longues parce qu'effectivement
celui qui a 4 à Sainte trimestre avant
la fin de l'année de l'âge d'un tel mais
pas de peau à chaque fois qu'on a eu des
discussions avec nos collègues ils m'ont
demandé tiens je suis questionné Ah bah
non il a que trois trimestres celui-là
et il en a pas quatre à cinq les
bordages c'est terrible c'est la raison
pour laquelle moi on en met mieux c'est
mais si on met pas des bandages dans
votre dispositif monsieur le ministre
vous me parlez des bornes pour le calcul
des cotisations alors soit les bornes
c'est bien soit les bornes c'est pas
bien vous avez mis des bornes de
cotisation différentes
4,5,15 au sud de 3,5 et puis en dessous
un taux différentiel j'en sais rien mais
des bornes à effectivement ça devient
incontournable quoi hein donc soyez
attentifs la CSG c'est déborde et là ça
veut dire effectivement vous me coûtez
trop cher donc finalement je vais vous
payer moins cher comme ça j'ai une
cotisation qui est en dessous donc on
voit bien que tout ça faut voir le
dispositif alors soit il y a une volonté
d'accepter le dispositif soit il y a
effectivement il y a la volonté de pas
l'accepter et mes chers collègues je
vous incite plutôt à aller dans le sens
de la Commission de façon à donner
davantage l'espoir au seniors merci
[Applaudissements]
nous allons donc
voter d'abord les sous amendements je
prends le bonheur oui oui non non vous
pouvez expliquer votre vote et aucun
problème et je vais et je signale que je
suis saisi du demande de scrutin public
sur l'amendement de la commission
présentée par les rapporteurs le 21/12
qui aura lieu à la fin de l'examen des
sous amendements pour le bon ordre de
nos débats
alors madame lui va merci monsieur le
président
moi je ne comprends pas pourquoi on est
toujours obligé de faire des cadeaux aux
entreprises pour que elle recrute des
gens soit c'est des jeunes soit c'est
des seniors soit c'est finalement et
alors les entreprises recrutent qui des
gens qui ont entre 25 et 55 ans et puis
après avant ça va pas après ça va plus
moi j'aurais préféré que l'on me demande
de juste aux entreprises en fonction de
certains critères de recruter ou de
maintenir un emploi des seniors pour
qu'elle puisse garder les diverses
exonérations auxquelles elles ont déjà
droit
on n'aurait pas eu besoin d'en rajouter
on leur demanderait un effort par
rapport à ce à quoi elles ont déjà droit
nous nous avons fait aussi par exemple
une proposition
de d'un recrutement ou enfin ou plutôt
de la présence d'un minimum de 15 % ou
d'un plancher de 15 % de seniors dans
les entreprises
en gérant le flux c'est à dire soit on
ne se débarrasse pas des gens de plus de
55 ans et lorsqu'on a des postes à
pourvoir on ne on ne comment dire on ne
se prive pas des candidatures de gens de
plus de 55 ans ça aurait déjà été un bon
me semble-t-il une bonne proposition
puis la dernière des remarques elle est
générale elle est d'ordre général le
Medef qui a été auditionné et que nous
avions vu aussi l'occasion d'auditionner
avec René Paul Savary le Medef est
particulièrement favorable à ce projet
de report de l'âge de recul de l'âge de
la retraite et dans le même temps
il y est favorable mais il refuse
catégoriquement de faire des efforts en
matière de recrutement des gens de plus
de 50 ans voilà donc j'ai envie de dire
ça devient un petit peu pénible quand
même et à un moment il faudra bien
trouver un moyen et moi je le propose
c'est au travers des exonérations déjà
existantes et je vais terminer en disant
que j'ai lu dans la presse ce matin que
le gouvernement je vous donne de la TVA
là
ce matin
on allait
loin de choses au printemps moi j'aurais
aimé qu'on pense automne c'est à dire
qu'on nous propose une loi travail avant
une loi retraite monsieur chanterelle et
chacun respecte bien son temps
merci monsieur le Président alors
monsieur le rapporteur Sabari vous aurez
dû renommer votre amendement
l'amendement Medef parce que c'est c'est
une commande directe du Medef cette
mesure va dans le bon sens a déclarer
Éric chevet le vice-président de la CPME
on n'est pas étonné de sa réaction parce
que avec ce CDI senior vous allez
permettre au patron d'être exonéré des
cotisations familles c'est à dire 5% du
salaire brut tout de même au passage le
ministre des comptes publics monsieur
Attal qui lui n'est pas là pour faire
une réforme de gauche mais pour serrer
la vis vous êtes à l'armée justement du
coup pour les finances publiques 800
millions d'euros
on se demande bien ce qui va rester des
économies prévues soit disant par la
réforme avec le recul de l'âge de départ
à la retraite mais veut revenons à la
proposition du rapporteur pourquoi donc
des honorations de cotisation famille
quel rapport avec l'emploi des sonneurs
aucun si ce n'est d'en profiter pour
siphonner la branche famille de la
sécurité sociale redevenu excédentaire
en 2021 non en fait c'est parce que
Monsieur Savary n'a pas eu le choix de
son propre aveu dans une entrevue que
vous avez donné à Ouest-France vous avez
dit il aurait été plus judicieux de
proposer une exonération de cotisations
chômage et oui mais la réforme des
retraites passe par un projet de loi
rectificatif de financement de la
sécurité sociale et l'assurance chômage
est en dehors de ce cadre voilà sur la
forme le résumé de toute l'absurdité du
débat que nous sommes en train d'avoir
mais sur le fond avec ce CDI dérégulé et
abaku que va-t-il se passer on risque de
mettre en concurrence des seniors avec
les jeunes sur le seul critère du coup
du travail or les jeunes eux-mêmes ont
aussi beaucoup de mal à s'insérer c'est
la raison pour laquelle monsieur sabery
nous voterons contre votre amendement je
suis gay
on a d'abord les effets
quand on a reporté l'âge légal de 60 à
62 ans ça a été nul sur l'embauche des
seniors qui n'était pas au travail nul
et donc les 1 million quatre de
personnes qui sont entre 53 et 69 ans
qui sont aujourd'hui sans emploi ni
revenus il y aura pas plus d'embauche
avec ce contrat dernier embauche
premièrement la deuxième l'argument de
du ministrateur est fort à propos là
aussi c'est qu'on va signer la branche
famille des cotisations sociales et on
va la sécher donc je n'y reviens pas
c'est mieux quand c'est lui qui le dit
plutôt que le groupe communiste dernière
chose
les exonérations de cotisations là on va
avoir un point divergent avec évidemment
monsieur le ministre
on a déjà quand même un certain nombre
de choses pour les évaluer par exemple
le cice qui s'est transformé en
exonération de cotisation je lis le
rapport France stratégie le dernier date
2020 les résultats restent conformes aux
conclusions des années précédentes un
fort effet emploi est trouvé chez le
quart des entreprises les plus
bénéficiaires du cice qui ne
représentent qu'un huitième des
effectifs mais rien ne significatif chez
les autres l'effet total restait Chimé à
100 000 emplois nous en avait promis un
million à l'époque ce qui est faible
rapporté au coût du cice de l'ordre de
18 milliards
10 jours pour 5000 emplois ça fait
180000 euros pour chaque emploi qu'on
sait que ça a l'air médian est aux
alentours de 33000 euros chargé donc
vous voyez ça ne marchera toujours pas
je vous remercie monsieur le Président
Madame Brulin
non mais sur les ministres mes chers
collègues c'est vrai que ce contrat en a
envie de l'appeler dernier embauche pour
les raisons que viennent de rappeler
Monique Lubin et Fabien gay
mais je suis pas davantage d'accord avec
le fait qu'on en dise que c'est un CDI
parce que un contrat dont on connaît
l'âge de début et l'âge de fin ça
ressemble quand même beaucoup plus à un
CDD qu'à un CDI
enfin les exonérations effectivement
sur la branche famille vous nous avez
expliqué monsieur le rapporteur que
votre préférence aurait été à des
exonérations chômage tout ça confirme
qu'on est quand même de plus en plus
dans du bricolage autour de cette
réforme et c'est ça n'est pas sans nous
inquiéter et puis ça donne quand même
l'impression que certains ici ne
supportent pas qu'une branche de notre
système de protection sociale soit
excédentaire la branche famille enfin
mes chers collègues on va entendre un
peu différemment tout ce que vous allez
nous dire prochainement sur ce que vous
voulez faire en direction des familles
quand dès que vous en avez l'occasion
vous diminuez les recettes pour la
branche famille on pourrait dire la même
chose de la branche accident du travail
maladie professionnelle qui elle aussi
est devenue excédentaire et qui à la
faveur de cette réforme va se voir aussi
spolier un certain nombre de ressources
on a bien compris monsieur le ministre
que les exonérations de cotisation
n'étaient pas tabou pour vous c'est même
malheureusement quasiment la seule
solution que vous mettez en avant à
quasiment chaque problème or il y a des
exonérations de cotisation qui se sont
multipliées pour les basses à l'air ce
qui a contribué à tirer les salaires
vers le bas qui des salaires qui sont
plutôt d'ailleurs le fait de début de
carrière et aujourd'hui on en prend
argument pour dire bah il faudrait aussi
des exonérations de cotisations pour les
fins de carrière parce que sinon ils
sont plus concurrentiels avec les débuts
de carrière et puis ensuite on va nous
dire bah écoutez pour tous les autres il
va falloir aussi des exonérations et
c'est comme ça qu'on arrive à la
situation que connaît notre financement
de la protection sociale nous proposons
de prendre le chemin exactement inverse
madame Bocquet
monsieur Bocquet c'est Madame briquet
auquel j'ai pensé non non j'ai aucun
doute on va bien chez le président
les semaines se suivent et de se
ressemblent pas la semaine dernière nous
combintions pieds à pied une aspiration
une réforme d'aspiration libérale votre
choix est depuis hier le monde a changé
de notre grâce à la presse nous
apprenons que nous contestons désormais
une réforme de gauche ce matin
je voulais partager avec vous ce
sentiment mes chers collègues sentiment
très étrange pour le groupe communiste
en attendant ce contrat de fin de
carrière censé favoriser l'embauche des
seniors s'appuie sur un seul argument
d'attractivité cela a été dit par mes
collègues l'exonération des cotisations
familiales de l'employeur exonération
que nous combattons parce que elles ont
le fâcheuse inconvénient de créer du
déficit de d'affaiblir les recettes d'un
régime et donc nous combattons pieds à
pied cette cette logique là alors
pensons sérieusement améliorer le taux
d'emploi des seniors qui est je le
rappelle de 56% pour les 55 64 ans en
exonérant les employeurs d'une
cotisation actuellement fixée à
3,45%, soit une économie de 129 euros
sur un salarié payé à 3745 euros vous
pensez résoudre la question des seniors
licenciés à 59 ans en baissant de 60
euros les cotisations des entreprises
sur un salaire médian qui franchement
croira à cette fable
monsieur le Président rénal
oui merci monsieur le Président et bien
comment dire j'ai le plaisir ce matin
d'être d'accord pour la première fois
avec des deux ministres présents et
j'allais dire sur l'ensemble des
arguments me semble-t-il bon
et voyez-vous je crois monsieur le
rapporteur je vous crois de bonne foi je
le dis dans votre recherche d'une
solution mais ensuite la bonne foi
n'excuse pas le fait qu'il faut entendre
des choses qui sont vraies et qui sont
me semble-t-il tout à fait justifiés
l'effet d'aubaine
bon ben ça ça existe toujours il y a
même un effet domaine qui pourrait être
encore plus plus terrible ça serait de
licencier un an avant et ensuite de
réembaucher selon un nouveau contrat pas
les mêmes personnes mais d'autres
personnes donc si vous voulez on connaît
les pratiques de certaines entreprises
c'est pas tous les chefs d'entreprise
heureusement mais de certains
entreprises qui jouent effectivement sur
les effets d'aubaine et nous les
connaissons
l'exonération famille j'y reviens pas
c'est curieux de proposer l'exonération
de famille mais vous l'avez expliqué
c'était pas votre objectif mais voilà et
puis leur envoi à le négociation
interprofessionnel c'est du bon sens
c'est du bon sens ou la BD d'ailleurs
vous-même il faut y revenir mais
laissons levenir laissons le venir de la
négociation interprofessionnelle
laissons chercher des solutions au
niveau au niveau des branches je pense
que c'est comme ça bon donc pour moi le
sujet numéro un d'ailleurs c'est pas
celui-là c'est d'abord de conserver les
seniors qui sont au travail avant de
savoir comment on réembauche comment
dans les entreprises on maintient les
gens au travail jusqu'à à l'âge à la fin
de la jelégale au minimum
donc moi je vous demanderai au vu de ce
qui s'est dit et de ce qui s'est dit de
manière tout à fait correcte
je vous remercierai monsieur le
rapporteur de considérer que vous avez
fait
œuvre utile que vous avez déposé un
amende à bande d'appel et que maintenant
au vu de ce qui s'est dit très
logiquement vous le retirez Madame A
pour ce poli
merci monsieur le Président alors nous
nous opposons évidemment fermement à cet
amendement des rapporteurs nous avons
déjà bien du mal à trouver je vous le
rappelle de l'emploi et un CDI pour les
jeunes et vous n'avez vous pour ligne de
mire que de tirer sur rognonbulance à
savoir évidemment exploiter jusqu'à la
dernière force des seigneurs et puis
vous avez certainement reçu évidemment
les félicitations du Medef pour votre
belle amendement parce qu'il le réclame
à corps et à Christ vous nous assumez de
cette réforme est une réforme de justice
sociale pourtant il s'agit bien notre
casser encore plus nos seigneurs avant
même de vous parler du droit au repos ou
comme vous aimez l'appeler ici dans
cette hémicycle le droit à la paresse
nous vous rappelons que le droit
fondamental au respect de la vie privée
familiale que vous torpillez que cela
soit avec la réforme mais également avec
cet
déconnecté complètement déconnecté de la
réalité du travail de la durée de la
dure réalité du labeur des salariés de
ce pays pour bien détrailleurs à chaque
jour suffit sa peine et par cet
amendement vous souhaitez nous vendre
comme de mauvais publicitaires que vous
êtes l'idée selon laquelle nos seniors
n'attendent qu'une seule chose continuer
continuer à travailler mes chers
collègues cet amendement ne parle à
personne si ce n'est qu'au patron vous
vous détachez de la réalité de millions
français de celle de millions de
travailleurs précaires pour favoriser
une foi encore les mêmes et vous
envisagez de les choyer de surcroît en
les exonération de cotisations sociales
ne pensez-vous pas qu'il est absolument
contre-productif de recruter des
personnes qui sont usées à des postes
qui nécessitent motivation et à
endurance votre amendement contrevient à
toute forme de pertinence et d'humanité
votre rons contre merci Monsieur
Chaumier
merci Monsieur président écoutez ce
dispositif au moins un mérite c'est
comme il comporte une disposition sur
les cotisations sociales et les
conformes à une LSS ce qui est pas le
cas de tous les articles donc il faut
quand même le noter pour le reste le
rapporteur a fait un lien intéressant
d'ailleurs à soudania entre la
production et les exonérations de
cotisation moi je veux dire j'ai regardé
les résultats ils sont pas flagrants
franchement depuis que cette politique
est devenue massive notamment depuis
on peut pas dire que la balance
commerciale de la France se soit
vraiment amélioré c'est fortement
dégradé et nos capacités de production
sont pas forcément en hausse c'est loin
qu'on puisse dire ça euphémisme donc la
question qui se pose c'est que ces
exonérations de cotisations surtout
elles sont un phénomène permanent de
modification de la dépense publique dans
notre pays c'est là où ce projet de loi
retraite a aussi un versant qui est
intéressant on transfère toujours plus
d'argent vers les entreprises la dépense
publique c'est une baisse des dépenses
en faveur des services publics et les
gens ils le voient partout autour d'eux
c'est pas la peine de répéter la justice
où elle en est la santé etc
c'est des dépenses vers les ménages et
là on y est au coeur avec la question
des retraites et c'est du transfert vers
les entreprises et quand on passe de
2018 à 2023 de 38 à 73 milliards d'euros
les exonérations de cotisations sociales
et qu'on augmente massivement les
transfert vers les entreprises il faut
bien prendre l'argent quelque part alors
on le prend sur les services publics qui
sont à l'os et quand même partout dans
nos départements c'est la catastrophe et
on le prend maintenant sur le transfert
vers les ménages là on voulant récupérer
de l'argent sur le système de retraite
alors tout ça est un choix politique
très clair mais il faut l'assumer
maintenant il faut l'assumer je suis
heureux qu'une part oui oui dans votre
camp chez les républicains il y a des
contenus qui ouvrent les yeux et qui
disent ça suffit on ne peut plus aller
dans ce sens là Monsieur Hénault
oui merci monsieur le Président violé
ministre d'abord une remarque monsieur
chanterelle a dit tout à l'heure que
monsieur le rapporteur répondait à une
commande du Medef je trouve cette
remarque désobligeante déplacée et ça
vous grandit pas voilà et comme vous
êtes coutumier du fait je voulais le
faire ce matin je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
bien sûr sur cette question sur cette
amendement nous avons un doute sur le
risque des phénomènes
nous avons naturellement ce doute moi
j'avoue que s'il y avait pas eu
l'article 40 d'ailleurs sans doute que
j'aurais déposé un amendement plutôt sur
une prime que sur une exonération ceci
dit j'ai été sensible aux arguments du
du rapporteur sur les les partenaires
sociaux et la négociation raison pour
laquelle je retire mes deux sous
amendements et je pense que on fait un
pari parce que si on si on n'augmente
pas la quantité de travail et la
quantité des seniors au travail bien
évidemment alors je suis sensible à
l'argument de Madame Rossignol et au
risque d'affaiblir le financement de la
branche famille mais on fait un pari et
ce Paris nous devons le faire
d'augmenter le taux de travail de des
seniors pour financer notre système de
retraite par répartition je pense
d'ailleurs et c'est raison pour laquelle
je retire ces deux sous amendements
ils nous devons chaque fois que nous
pouvons laisser le plus de l'attitude
possible à la négociation des
partenaires sociaux c'est l'état
d'esprit qui est celui de notre groupe
si nous voulons aussi redonner du grain
à moudre et faire en sorte qu'on ait un
pari tarisme refondé et rénové et ce
sera une des questions de de la loi
travail à venir je vous remercie merci
Monsieur Breuillet
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues j'ai commencé
par un point d'accord avec ce que vient
de dire monsieur Hainaut je pense
qu'effectivement il s'agit d'un chantier
qui devrait être ouvert avec les
partenaires sociaux dans la négociation
interprofessionnelle avant de venir en
débat parmi nous bien sûr il y a un
énorme problème du travail des seniors
nous l'avons d'ailleurs évoqué
longuement hier à propos de l'index pour
lequel il y a un refus de toute mesure
contraignante
ce chantier devrait donc être ouvert
avec les partenaires sociaux et je veux
dire un point d'accord avec le ministre
Attal aussi sur les critiques qu'il fait
du dispositif un point d'accord
notamment lorsqu'il critique les mesures
de bornes
mais j'espérais qu'il y avait pas de à
cet état des mesures de bornes alors
c'est moi qui est qui est
j'avais mal compris ce mini j'ai pensé
qu'il pouvait y avoir un sous-entendu
donc c'était juste les mesures d'âge
pardon mais effectivement il peut y
avoir un effet de bornes ou de seuil
avec une mesure comme celle-là et
notamment qui impacterait les gens âgés
de 58 59 ans dans la question de l'accès
à l'emploi et tout aussi importante et
puis enfin dernière remarque on parle
toujours d'exonération et ensuite on
parle toujours des déficits de
l'ensemble des caisses publiques donc
comme l'a évoqué un collègue et je
m'excuse de ne pas le citer avant moi je
suggère effectivement qu'on diminue pour
inciter les entreprises embauchées
peut-être dans le cadre de l'index qu'on
diminue les très nombreuses exonérations
qui leur sont accordés à celles qui ne
respectent pas le taux d'emploi des
seniors ou et qu'on les maintiennent à
celles qui embauche en tous les cas
qu'on
souligne l'intérêt de maintenir ses
exonérations uniquement pour ceux qui
embauchent réellement ou qui servent des
enjeux climatiques
monsieur le Président Retailleau
moi je considère que
l'amendement de René Paul Savary que
nous allons voter évidemment
révèle un enjeu qui est un des plus
grand de cette réforme parce que à quoi
servirait-il d'augmenter de reculer
l'âge légal de départ si on ne fait rien
sur l'emploi des seniors vous savez
parfaitement que le taux de chômage et
un certain nombre de sénatrices et de
sénateurs de l'opposition l'ont répété
hier touche tout particulièrement les
seniors et nous nous contentons pas de
ce que nous dit le gouvernement le
gouvernement dit mais nous on a un outil
extraordinaire c'est l'index l'index est
une statistique certes il y aura l'effet
diamondshine en bon vendéen pardon mais
ça n'est pas suffisant nous voulons
trouver un autre outil et c'est ce qu'a
fait la commission la commission nous a
dit on peut peut-être trouver à travers
ce nouveau contrat qui va s'adresser à
des seniors un outil qui permettra de
lutter contre le chômage des seniors
vous faites plusieurs reproches je vais
y répondre René Paul Savary a répondu au
reproches de la négociation avec les
partenaires sociaux il y a trois
reproches essentiellement vous n'êtes
dites un effet d'Aubade oui il y aurait
eu un effet d'aubaine si le contrat
s'adressait au plus de 60 ans qui sont
déjà dans l'entreprise non là ça ne sera
pas le cas ce sera des gens qu'on va
sortir du chômage et qui vont rentrer
sur le marché du travail première chose
et vous savez parfaitement parfaitement
qu'on embauche très très peu en France
après 60 ans donc il y a pas d'effet
d'Aubagne il y a pas d'effet d'Auber
deuxième reproche que vous faites sur le
coup nous contestons formellement nous
contestons formellement le coût du
gouvernement nous le contestons parce
que le gouvernement
ne regarde qu'une ligne la ligne de la
dépense mais il s'agit d'activer en
réalité des dépenses chômage
d'indemnisation et il s'agit de faire en
sorte que des gens qui bénéficient
bénéficier parce qu'ils ont un emploi
des économies sont chiffrés ce à quoi
revient par exemple 100 000 seniors
qu'on réintègre sur le marché du travail
c'est près d'un milliard donc vous voyez
que c'est une mesure qui à notre sens ne
coûtera pas mais au contraire rapportera
et troisième élément troisième reproche
que vous avez fait ça va assécher la
branche famille non puisque pour
l'instant ils sont au chômage il n'y a
pas de cotisation famille donc il s'agit
encore une fois et c'est l'esprit
d'ailleurs de la réforme de réactiver et
de faire en sorte le taux d'activités
dans l'économie pardon monsieur le
président
madame le héros
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président excusez-moi
vous proposez d'instaurer un nouveau
type de contrat de travail afin de
favoriser l'emploi d'un seigneur mais la
question n'est pas de créer un nouveau
CDI mais que les entreprises gardent
leur salarié de 55 ans et plus votre
proposition risque de mettre en
concurrence des seniors avec les jeunes
sur le seul critère du coup du travail
sachant que les jeunes aussi ont du mal
à s'insérer vous exonérer les
entreprises de cotisation familiale donc
vous ponctionnez ça vient d'être dit les
caisses d'allocations familiales la
protection sociale de nos familles or
nous savons que cette politique
familiale a besoin de moyens pour mettre
en place un vrai service public de la
petite enfance il nous manque des places
en crèche nous avons besoin de moyens
pour financer les congés pour l'égalité
femme homme soit une soit en réalité
tout simplement le l'égalité
professionnelle qui passe aussi par une
égalité des droits des deux parents à
accompagner l'arrivée de l'enfant dans
le foyer
nous avons besoin de cotisations pour
compenser les congés de maternité alors
que les femmes pour que les femmes et
les mêmes droits au départ à la retraite
d'ailleurs monsieur le ministre du shop
avec le la première ministre vous
considériez initialement que les
exonérations de cotisation n'était pas
le meilleur moyen pour agir sur l'emploi
des seniors alors quels sont les
éléments qui vous ont fait changer
d'avis il serait intéressant pour nous
de les connaître pour notre part nous ne
changeons pas d'avis le meilleur moyen
de maintenir les seigneurs en emploi
jusque 62 ans et de ne pas changer l'âge
légal de départ nous savons déjà que un
salarié sur deux n'est pas un emploi sur
la tranche d'âge des 50-64 ans de 55 64
ans merci Madame Ferré
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je voulais
revenir sur la question du véhicule
législatif vous allez me dire encore et
toujours oui encore et toujours parce
que à nouveau avec cette article
additionnel et bien on voit que le
véhicule législatif que le gouvernement
a choisi n'est pas le bon vous avez dit
je vais revenir sur les propos de
Monsieur le rapporteur il aurait été
plus judicieux de proposer une
exonération de cotisations chômage dans
la mesure où l'embauche de seigneur
réduit le chômage oui mais problème nous
sommes dans une loi de finances
rectificative et l'assurance chômage
étant dehors de ce cadre alors oui ce
véhicule législatif n'est décidément pas
le bon s'agissant des exonérations et la
proposition qui est faite d'exonérer au
travers de ce CDI comme ma collègue je
m'interroge c'est dit c'est qu'on a pas
de fin quand on ne connaît pas la fin là
on la connaît cette date de fin puisque
c'est la date de départ en retraite de
la personne qui serait recruter donc
plutôt de ce CDD monsieur le ministre
vous vous on dit les exonérations de
cotisations ne sont pas le meilleur
moyen pour développer l'emploi des
seigneurs des seniors pour moi pardon
pour moi ce n'est pas le meilleur moyen
c'est ça n'est pas le moyen pour
développer l'emploi des seniors c'est
effectivement monsieur atteint le
ministre que vous avez dit que le coût
de cet amendement serait de 800 millions
d'euros c'est pas rien c'est pas rien
tout comme si on additionne et si on
regarde l'ensemble du coup ou l'ensemble
des exonérations employeurs qui sont de
l'ordre de 80 milliards d'euros alors
cessons de faire des propositions qui
pourraient convenir plutôt et je le dis
moi aussi
sans complexe et en assumant
complètement ce que je dis qui sont de
véritables cadeaux aux entreprises ce
sont d'être dans cette volonté d'aider
les entreprises et non pas celles et
ceux qui sont sans emploi parce que
aussi le risque est réel de mettre en
concurrence les seniors et les jeunes
avec
ce seul critère du coût du travail
madame la Présidente Laurence Rossignol
merci monsieur le Président je n'imagine
pas que cet amendement puisse être autre
chose qu'un amendement d'appel et je
voudrais faire quelques remarques
d'abord au ministre qui nous dit j'ai
pas de tabou sur les ingénérations
sociales
oui un peu quand même vous en avez
monsieur le ministre parce que 75
milliards annuels d'exonération de
charges sociales et un discours
permanent sur les déficits publics mais
jamais aucun lien n'est fait entre le
montant le volume des exonérations de
charge sociale et le montant des
déficits publics pour autant il y en a
un et celui-là il est toujours dans le
tabou puisque vous n'en parlez pas
deuxième remarque c'est que vous
monsieur Savary et je pense que vous
êtes sincère quand vous le dites vous
renvoyez à la négocié à la consultation
des partenaires sociaux permettant de
vous dire que en ce moment sur la
consultation des partenaires sociaux à
l'initiative de ce gouvernement on est
pour le moins prudent sur la nature de
cette concertation et ce que les
partenaires sociaux pourraient obtenir
comme garantie dans une négociation
gouvernement qui a décidé de ne plus de
s'émanciper de la vie des partenaires
sociaux en matière de politique sociale
parce que dans cet amendement moi j'ai
pas tout compris mais peut-être que
peut-être j'ai pas été assez comment
dire rigoureuse ou attentive vous avez
dit tout à l'heure que l'employeur
s'engage à garder le salarié nonobstant
l'ensemble de toutes les autres règles
du Code du travail concernant le
licenciement par exemple je n'imagine
pas qu'il s'agisse d'un engagement qui
émancive et qui protège le travailleur
dans toutes les circonstances donc
comment ça s'articuler avec le
licenciement habituel pour faute pour le
sentiment économique plan social à ce
moment-là il y a plus d'engagement donc
là on a besoin quand même je crois de
retravailler un peu et puis tout à
l'heure le président Retailleau nous a
dit que à la fois que il voyait pas bien
enfin qu'il y avait un lien entre cet
amendement et le recul d'âge et puis
notre collègue Olivier Hainaut a dit que
c'était un pari alors moi j'aime bien
que les paris soit équitables il y a ça
c'est un pari mais le recul d'âge dans
l'esprit du gouvernement c'est pas un
pari c'est un coup près qui va qui va
qui s'appliquerait dès le vote de la loi
merci Monsieur fichier
[Musique]
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre c'est juste une précision
parce que Corinne fERRER on a fait état
tout à l'heure on parle de CDI mais en
fait c'est un CDD dont il s'agit à CDD
de 4 ans puisqu'il sera signé à l'âge de
60 ans et à 64 ans c'est terminé il y a
donc une sorte de CDD vieux ou de
contrats de dernière embauche en fait en
plus on ne peut pas comprendre le fait
que ça s'arrête à 64 ans puisque si les
personnes souhaitent aller jusqu'à 70
ans ce n'est que mieux puisque c'est
même personne pendant ce temps-là
démarreront pas aux caisses de retraite
donc autant d'économie de fait je crois
que du coup ça vaut le coup d'y
réfléchir je vous remercie et Madame
meunier
c'est le président monsieur le ministre
chers collègues tout d'abord moi je
voudrais dire que je me réjouis de la
tonalité de nos propos et de la belle
qualité des débats ce matin ça augure je
pense d'une belle semaine à venir
monsieur Savary le rapporteur ça varie
vous avez dit vous-même que par cet
amendement qui n'est qu'un outil nouveau
c'est ainsi que vous l'avez qualifié
certes mais c'est un outil au service
d'une mécanique que nous ne voulons pas
donc désolé mais ne
voterai pas votre amendement monsieur le
ministre Attal vous avez dit que c'était
un risque mais c'est l'ensemble du
projet de loi qui est un risque un
risque pour les personnes qui sont
concernées les plus modestes celles qui
ont travaillé dans des métiers les plus
difficiles et qui verront de fait deux
ans supplémentaires de cotisations avant
de partir à la retraite et puis dites
que vous n'avez pas de tabous ça a été
souligné tout à l'heure des tabous
concernant les exonérations et ça je
veux bien vous croire par contre vous
avez des tabous concernant les recettes
et les possibilités de recettes
nouvelles nous vous en avons fait de ce
côté de l'hémicycle et vous persistez à
ne pas les entendre la taxation sur les
supers profits les contributions sur les
eaux salaires et les grosses fortunes et
toutes celles que nous avons pu aussi
décliner que déclinerons tout au long de
ce débat merci merci
monsieur le Président
moi je rejoins tout à fait ce que disait
tout à l'heure le président Retailleau
si on ne fait rien pour inciter à
l'embauche des seniors on passe à côté
d'un point essentiel cette réforme
j'ai auditionné avec le groupe le
professeur Lorenzi président du Cercle
des économistes qui a calculé que si en
France nous rattrapions tout simplement
le déficit dans l'emploi des seniors
rappelle que ces 10 points de déficit
par rapport à la moyenne de l'OCDE ça
rapporterait 13 milliards
pour notre système de retraite 13
milliards
je crois que les chiffres parlent
d'eux-mêmes
d'ailleurs je crois que monsieur le
ministre dans vos
papiers notamment ceux qui nous ont été
donnés lorsque nous avions fait le bilan
d'étape vous parliez de pour cent mille
emplois créés le Seigneur un milliard de
recettes supplémentaires vous pouvez le
confirmer j'imagine aisément je les ai
lu ce sont des chiffres qui nous
permettent d'envisager et je rejoins
tout à fait la position que
défendait tout à l'heure Olivier Hainaut
plutôt une prime à l'embauche que des
exonérations
les exonérations on le sait tous les
PLFSS on se plaint des exonérations et
l'État est obligé de compenser les
exonérations depuis le vote de la loi
organique n'est-ce pas monsieur ministre
donc je crois que le plus simple ce
serait de mettre une prime à l'embauche
quant à un emploi rapporte un fait qu'un
100.000 emplois rapportent un milliard
on sait qu'on peut libérer effectivement
quelques centaines de millions pour
pouvoir permettre à des seniors de
retrouver effectivement la dignité du
travail merci
[Applaudissements]
et ensuite ce sera le président Gontard
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres je crois que à travers les
discussions que nous avons nous
constatons très bien qu'il ne s'agit pas
dans une proposition de loi de gauche
plus on avance plus on se rend compte
que cette proposition est que les
différentes propositions qui sont faits
également notamment celles qui a été
faite par notre rapporteur et bien ne
correspondent pas il faudrait une vraie
loi pour parler de la retraite pour
parler du travail des jeunes des jeunes
et pour parler des seniors parce que là
on est dans la confusion on est dans le
bricolage et ce n'est pas le bon
véhicule pour aller en Guadeloupe je
prends l'avion je ne vais pas prendre
une trottinette donc eh bien on est dans
un cas de figure qui serait similaire
donc je crois aujourd'hui que nous
devons être sérieux nous devons
travailler dans l'intérêt premier des
seniors et là la façon d'aborder les
choses dans l'appréhender s'apparente à
une façon de les maltraiter les des
entreprises parce que les éléments qui
sont évoqués chacun a entendu mais c'est
pas c'est pas normal ce n'est pas normal
parler de la voie de famille moi je veux
bien parce qu'il y a beaucoup à faire et
ma collègue vient de discuter de
proposer un certain nombre de pistes
nous ne pouvons pas faire n'importe quoi
nous ne devons pas faire n'importe quoi
dans mon territoire la question des
jeunes se pose beaucoup plus que des
seniors mais les seigneurs aussi donc
nous devons mettre en oeuvre tout ce
qu'il faut tous les moyens pour une
vraie loi de retraite et ne pas faire
n'importe quoi pour les seniors les
maltraités c'est maltraités les enfants
c'est maltraiter les plus jeunes c'est
maltraiter la société merci président
comptable
se prépare oui merci merci monsieur le
Président moi très rapidement je voulais
juste lever peut-être une petite
incohérence parce que j'ai écouté le
président Retailleau tout à l'heure et
puis j'ai regardé ce qu'il avait pu dire
et dans une belle envolée je crois que
c'était hier sur les bienfaits du recul
de l'âge et il nous disait le recul de
l'âge procure un autre avantage nous
allons automatiquement mécaniquement
augmenter le temps d'emploi des seniors
et ainsi mettre plus de travail dans la
machine et donc je m'étonne un petit peu
que du coup aujourd'hui on nous explique
bah que non justement mécaniquement
automatiquement ça ne fonctionnera pas
mais qu'il faut un dispositif un autre
dispositif peut-être de l'huile du coup
dans la machine pour pouvoir employer
ces seniors donc c'est vrai que là je
vois une petite une petite incohérence
que j'aimerais bien lever parce que ça
me paraît important d'ailleurs un de vos
collègues nous ont dit si on ne fait
rien on aura on aura tout faux donc
voilà j'aimerais essayer de
comprendre parce que c'est vrai que si
justement ce bien fait de l'âge de recul
à la retraite ces fameux deux ans vont
nous permettre mécaniquement il me
semble que ce dispositif pour le coup ne
sert à rien à moins que ça soit
simplement un faux CDI et simplement une
voie de garage
merci merci monsieur le Président sur le
dispositif qui nous est proposé on ne
peut que contester son existence parce
que le problème c'est sa finalité qu'on
a du mal à percevoir c'est quoi la vraie
finalité de ce contrat qui est un
contrat dont on imagine mal la portée
dans le temps avec toutes les limites
qui ont été qui ont été imposées et puis
on a entendu monsieur le ministre
monsieur Attal nous dire que cette
disposition aurait un effet particulier
puisqu'elle coûte elle coûterait 800
millions d'euros mais je suis un peu
surpris par la dualité du discours parce
que quand il s'agit de supprimer la taxe
d'habitation à peu près 26 milliards
d'euros dont 8 milliards pour les 20%
les les plus les plus aisés quand on
supprime la CVAE là
l'exécutif fait des paris et on n'a pas
du tout de vision sur ce qui vont être
ou ce qui pourrait être les conséquences
c'est des paris par contre quand il est
question d'augmenter même de manière
modérée les recettes sociales pour
financer la protection sociale là ce
n'est plus possible d'en parler il y a
tout un ensemble de solutions qui
existent et que nous vous proposons
régulièrement comme l'augmentation du
taux d'emploi des seniors comme
l'égalité homme-femme comme simplement
comme l'a montré Thomas Piketty
l'augmentation de 2% de la CSG sur les
hauts patrimoine qui viendrait compenser
l'ensemble des besoins du système de
retraite la vraie question c'est
pourquoi d'un côté vous êtes
relativement timoré et pourquoi de
l'autre il faudrait alors vous faire
confiance à vos gel
oui merci monsieur le Président je
voulais aller dans le sens du de mon
collègue Guillaume Gontard pour dire que
nous trouvons ici dans une situation un
peu un peu curieuse on a d'un côté dans
ce côté-là de l'hémicycle des collègues
qui nous disent cette réforme est
nécessaire et elle est très utile
notamment pour l'emploi des seniors
parce automatiquement en augmentant
l'âge légal de départ à la retraite on
va augmenter le nombre de seniors en
emploi et en même temps on nous dit si
on crée part un CDI senior ou peu
importe comment il s'appelle exactement
on passe à côté de l'élément essentiel
de cette réforme qui est absent
aujourd'hui du projet de loi donc déjà
est-ce qu'on pourrait peut-être se
mettre d'accord entre nous sur le fait
de dire que le recul de l'âge de départ
à la retraite ne crée pas d'emploi chez
les seniors puisque les républicains ont
eux-mêmes déposé un amendement pour
réparer ce qu'ils ont ce qu'il décrivait
comme pourtant étant déjà dans la
réforme ça c'est une première chose la
deuxième chose c'est que bon moi j'avais
pas ces chiffres en tête mais je je les
crois bien volontiers notre collègue
vient de nous dire si on avait si on
corrigé l'écart de d'emploi des seniors
en France par rapport à la moyenne de
l'UE on aurait 13 milliards dans les
caisses c'est à dire en gros bien ce que
ce qu'on cherche c'est de l'ordre de 13
milliards qu'on cherche et on a un
dispositif qu'on nous propose qui
consiste à baisser les cotisations donc
à appauvrir les caisses la sécurité
sociale donc on marche sur la tête d'un
côté on nous dit cette réforme va
permettre d'augmenter l'emploi des
seniors mais comme elle ne le fait pas
on a besoin d'un outil qui va nous
permettre que l'emploi des seniors donne
moins dans les caisses la sécurité
sociale dont nous avons besoin pour
financer les retraites je veux dire à un
moment donné il y a un aspect de pure
cohérence intellectuelle qui m'échappe
totalement
madame line
[Musique]
on voit bien que cette proposition
d'une part c'est le constat du fait que
ça va aggraver la situation des seniors
certes il y aura quelques créations de
prolongement mais le gros du paquet va
rester ni emploi ni
retraite et comme d'habitude la seule
idée qui vient à droite c'est que je
générer des cotisations sociales ça fait
des lustres
que vous avez des contrats de ceci
premier embauche dernier machin là ça va
être dernier embauche et l'efficacité je
m'excuse de dire c'est la bulle par
contre l'assèchement des comptes de la
protection sociale ça c'est du sérieux
alors
parlons des cotisations
s'il y avait l'égalité salariale femme
qui est peut-être quand même plus facile
à atteindre que de faire travailler des
gens qui pour une part sont dans des
situations très difficiles pour pouvoir
travailler on aurait déjà fait la moitié
de vos 13 milliards là on en serait à 6
ou 7 deuxièmement ça fait des années des
années qu'on explique que les
exonérations de cotisations sociales si
elles sont elles peuvent être
pertinentes elles ne le peuvent être
qu'à deux conditions la première c'est
qu'elle soit ciblée vers des activités
par exemple pour accompagner la
réindustrialisation l'évolution de la
transition écologique etc et si elles
sont conditionnées c'est à dire s'il y a
des garanties au lieu de créer le énième
la énième cotisation allégée
exigée que pour avoir l’allègement
l'équivalent c'est du du contrat du
au long de la contrat bon bref
[Musique]
c'est voilà merci la contrepartie de
l'équivalence cice soit conditionné un
accord ou à des engagements concernant
toutes les séries de critères dont
l'augmentation de la part des seniors là
vous ne faites pas dépenses
supplémentaires vous ciblez merci alors
je vais maintenant donner la parole il
n'y a plus de bande d'explication de
vote à Madame la rapporteur général
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues j'ai entendu
parler de concurrence entre les jeunes
et les vieux alors là c'est quelque
chose que que j'ai du mal à entendre
parce que je crois que alors je me suis
peut-être idéaliste mais en réalité je
crois à l'utilité de chacun dans la
société il y a pas de mise en
concurrence de telles catégories
vis-à-vis de telle autre je pense qu'on
a dans ce pays parfois penser à des
politiques spécifiques pour les jeunes
on a moins pensé aux politiques
spécifiques pour les seniors c'est
dommage il y a quand même un territoire
le Val-de-Marne qui a pensé et nous
avons auditionné d'ailleurs les acteurs
de ce dispositif qui s'appelle label +
45 et c'était très intéressant de les
entendre parce que en réalité on
pourrait déployer ce type de dispositif
un petit peu partout c'est à dire
sensibiliser l'entreprise sensibilité la
population parce que comme je le disais
hier c'est notre société qui doit
changer de mentalité vis-à-vis de nos
aînés les aînés ont des choses à
transmettre les aînés ont des choses à
dire aux jeunes alors que on a de plus
en plus de d'apprentis dans notre dans
nos territoires on devrait justement
capitaliser si c'est un terme qui ne
vous plaît pas moi je pense qu'on peut
capitaliser sur le savoir des anciens et
donc un contrat tel que il est proposé
est aussi sur cette dimension là cette
idéale là de transmettre et de et de
permettre à nos seniors et bien
d'apporter aux jeunes une sorte de
tutorat de mantorat qui est utile alors
c'est vrai que ce contrat est sans doute
pas bien écrit et qui qu'il faut y
repenser mais il y a effectivement une
loi travail qui qui arrive donc on
pourra le travailler ensemble si je puis
dire mais je voudrais reparler aussi de
l'index Seigneur parce que moi il me
semble que dans cette index le Seigneur
il faudra penser dans la loi de travail
à y mettre un bonus on est toujours à
parler de punir punir punir mais on sait
on peut aussi dire quand c'est bien et
quand on valorise des bonnes initiatives
et donc dans l'index Seigneur et bien il
faudra justement regarder comment on
peut mettre en avant les très bonnes
initiatives et je pense que des CDI vers
les seniors c'est une très belle
initiative
sans allonger les débats mais elle me
semble
indispensable non je ne suis pas
asservie au MEDEF à tel point que
j'accepte bien volontiers l'indicateur
je crois pas que ce soit le Medef qui
réclame l'indicateur mais permettez-moi
de vous dire que
j'ai des relations toujours
respectueuses avec les différents
partenaires sociaux que ce soit le Medef
FO j'ai eu l'occasion de rencontrer
auditionné son secrétaire général je
rencontre régulièrement madame pizza
puisqu'elle est présidente de l'argile
Carco et puis d'autres dans le cadre du
corps et Monique Lubin c'est bien les
discussions qu'on peut avoir au niveau
du corps on évite effectivement de
parler ce qu'il fâche sinon on en
sortirait pas une fois qu'on a dit ça on
peut parler d'autre chose et notamment
de l'employabilité des seniors et c'est
comme ça que à force de discussion est
venue cette idée pas inventé si vous
voulez je voulais remettre un petit peu
ça vous le dire en toute en toute
intéressé donc indépendant de tout cela
vous voyez vous j'ai pas effectivement
écouter toutes les propositions de tout
j'en ai choisi quelques-unes
deuxièmement
il a été
dit à travers une intervention que il
fallait plutôt que s'occuper des seniors
au chômage qu'il fallait mieux s'occuper
des seniors en emploi oui aussi les
seigneurs en emploi c'est pour ça que
notamment vous êtes les premiers à
dénoncer ce qu'on dénonce aussi qu'il
faut prendre des mesures pour les maires
de famille et les mesures des mers de
famille qu'on va vous proposer c'est
effectivement parce que elle reste en
emploi un peu plus longtemps peut-être
avec l'effet de décalage de l'âge mais
surtout avec l'effet de la réforme
Touraine mais heureux proposez pas
d'être inhumain de faire de vouloir
particulièrement mettre les seniors au
travail c'est l'application de la
réforme Touraine on travaille 43 ans
quand vous voyez vous avez commencé à 20
ans vous travaillez 43 ans mais quand
vous avez commencé à travailler à 22 ans
à vous travaillez jusqu'à quel âge
jusqu'au 65 ans c'est la réforme
Touraine l'effet d'âge effectivement
effectivement il peut avoir aussi un
effet mais je voudrais qu'on soit clair
entre nous très clair entre nous
c'est pas 43 ans plus deux ans d'où au
travail supplémentaire soit disant de 62
à 64 non non c'est l'ajustement des
bornes et effectivement de par la
réforme Touraine certains seront ou
certaines seront amenés à travailler
plus longtemps et d'autres parler fait
de l'âge légal seront à travailler
quelques mois également plus longtemps
peut-être année pour certaines
générations mais c'est pas deux ans de
plus pour tout le monde arrêtez de
vendre un argument qui est faux parce
qu'effectivement ça contribue à mettre
les gens dans la rue mais si on leur
explique bien
la différence elle est quand même
importante
[Applaudissements]
voilà donc je ne suis pas le bourreau
des seniors que vous prétendez que je
sois ensuite effectivement il y a eu il
y a eu des propositions de la belle
Jean-Marie Arena herberg un garçon sage
Jean-Marie il connaît bien le dispositif
il connaît bien les syndicats et il est
pas servi non plus un syndicat mais ne
connaît bien ben écoutez moi je partage
aussi ça un index à pénalise un label ça
valorise bon on peut peut-être trouver
un équilibre entre les deux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président très
rapidement je veux pas contribuer à
allonger les débats je pense qu'on a été
suffisamment éclairé mais je dois
répondre à quelques points qui ont été
évoqués qui peuvent je pense être utile
dans les choix que les uns et les autres
feront au moment du vote si l'amendement
n'est pas retiré d'abord pour répondre à
monsieur vandlerenberg je vous rejoins
totalement
sur la question du taux d'emploi si on
avait le même taux d'emploi en France
que nos voisins allemands moi j'aurais
pas de travail j'en aurai beaucoup moins
pour équilibrer les comptes puisque les
recettes supplémentaires induite par 10
points de taux d'emploi en plus nous
permettrait d'équilibrer en tout cas
d'équilibrer beaucoup mieux nos budgets
donc la question c'est comment est-ce
qu'on améliore le taux d'emploi
améliorer le taux d'emploi ça veut dire
travailler sur les jeunes et c'est donc
tout ce qu'on a fait notamment sur
l'apprentissage ce qu'on doit faire sur
la réforme du lycée professionnel qui
aujourd'hui objectivement ne permet pas
d'insérer véritablement les jeunes dans
l'emploi et donc c'est une réforme qui
est particulièrement importante et deux
sur les seniors et donc oui on doit
s'interroger collectivement sur les
mesures les plus efficaces pour
améliorer le taux d'emploi des seniors
et c'est vrai et je réponds à Madame
Vogel notamment c'est vrai que la
réforme de 2010 a permis une
amélioration du taux d'emploi des
seniors de 15 points depuis 2010 toutes
les études qui ont été réalisées le
disent et il y a pas eu besoin de
contrats spécifiques après la réforme
Fillon de 2010 pour améliorer de 15
points le taux d'emploi des seniors mais
évidemment qu'on doit penser à des
mesures supplémentaires il y a l'index
il peut y en avoir d'autres moi j'ai
entendu leur rapporteur général comme
Monsieur Vandenberg dire que ce
dispositif de CDI seniors était
peut-être pas le mieux abouti donc moi
je proposerai volontiers de retirer cet
amendement et qu'on retravaille les
choses peut-être en vue de la loi
travail ou du prochain PLFSS mais encore
une fois prendre une mesure qui
coûterait 800 millions d'euros à la
branche famille sans qu'on est garantie
sur son efficacité vous avez parlé de
Paris mais je suis pas totalement
convaincu et pour répondre à Monsieur
Retailleau l'effet d'aubaine ça serait
si toutes les entreprises qui ont
actuellement un contrat avec un seigneur
de plus de 60 ans le transformer en CDI
senior là ça serait 2 milliards 300
millions d'euros donc c'est pas ça dont
je parle quand je parle des 800 millions
d'euros le coût de 800 millions d'euros
c'est le coût pour les seniors qui
aujourd'hui rentrent dans un contrat
après 60 ans vous en avez 100 000 à peu
près chaque année qui sont recrutés on
imagine assez bien qu'un chef
d'entreprise qui recrute un seigneur qui
a plus de 60 ans il a chaud entre le CDI
classique sans allègement de cotisation
sur la branche famille et le CDI senior
où il a cinq points de cotisation en
moins sur
les cotisations familles il va plutôt
choisir le CDI seniors donc d'ores et
déjà pour les seniors qui sont
aujourd'hui recrutés sans qui ai besoin
disponible supplémentaires ça coûte 800
millions d'euros donc peut-être qu'il y
en aura d'autres qui le seront à ce
moment-là en plus mais enfin il en
faudrait beaucoup pour que ça compense
les frais avant de conclure je veux
juste revenir sur la question des
allègements et des exonérations de
cotisation ça a été abordé et j'ai
entendu parler notamment monsieur
kerouge de dualité dans le discours etc
il y a eu depuis 20 ans deux grandes
étapes d'allègement de cotisations pour
les entreprises
la première de ces deux grandes étapes
depuis 20 ans c'est le PLFSS 2014
présenté à l'époque de François Hollande
avec notamment les allègements et les
exonérations maladie et familles pour 25
milliards d'euros 25 milliards d'euros
dans le PLFSS 2014 je suis allé regarder
j'ai demandé à mon équipe de Me
ressortir le scrutin public de l'époque
l'intégralité du groupe socialiste à
l'époque avait voté la mesure
d'exonération de 25 milliards d'euros de
cotisations maladie et famille à
l'exception de trois sénateurs je décide
quand même madame linmann qui à l'époque
n'avait pas souhaité le voter et
Monsieur Godefroy et monsieur godini qui
ne sont ne siège plus mais le groupe
socialiste à l'époque avait voté 25
milliards d'euros de baisse de
cotisations pour les entreprises ensuite
la deuxième étape c'est la
transformation du cice en baisse de
cotisation 2019 Emmanuel Macron
président de la République ce qui est
intéressant de regarder c'est contre
avant la transformation du cice en
baisse de cotisation et aujourd'hui
on perçoit aujourd'hui 21 milliards de
recettes en plus pour la sécurité
sociale parce que comme on a baissé les
cotisations il y a plus d'embauches un
million 500000 de plus et donc on
perçoit aujourd'hui plus de recettes
puisqu'il y a plus de personnes qui
travaillent pour la sécurité sociale
donc oui alléger les cotisations a
permis d'élargir le nombre de
recrutement et donc d'avoir des recettes
supplémentaires pour la sécu donc pour
ces raisons-là c'est pour ça que je dis
j'ai pas de tabou sur la question des
baisses de cotisation merci Monsieur
Louis allons passer maintenant au vote
nous avons commencé par l'amendement
4741 madame Dubos ceux qui sont
favorables sur l'adoption manifeste en
levant la main
avis contraire
attention il n'est pas adopté
un sous amendement qui a été présenté
par
Monsieur Dufour madame guidez il est
maintenu
il est pas vaincu merci un amendement
4742 présenté par Madame Lubin ceux qui
sont pour
amis contraire
abstention je pense que nous avons le
même vote pour le suivant
il est et le suivant aussi il est il ne
sont pas adoptés et nous allons passer
au vote pas scrutin public demandez par
le groupe communiste républication
citoyen écologiste de l'abandon de la
Commission du portant le numéro 21 et
les sénateurs sont donc en train de
voter sur le CDI senior c'est la
proposition que fait la majorité de
droite et du centre du Sénat dans cette
réforme des retraites sur la question de
l'emploi des seniors ce CDI senior
consiste en des contrats pour les
salariés de plus de 60 ans demandeurs
d'emploi des contrats avec une
exonération de cotisations sur la
branche famille de la sécurité sociale
le but c'est d'inciter les entreprises à
embaucher des salariés de plus de 60 ans
alors qu'on sait que justement le taux
de chômage se creuse pour cette
catégorie de la population alors le
gouvernement a émis un avis défavorable
car il estime que cette mesure est trop
coûteuse notamment pour la sécurité
social avec cette exonération de charge
sur la branche famille et la gauche a
dénoncé cette politique d'exonération de
cotisation sociale pour favoriser
l'emploi car elle estime que cela va
affaiblir les finances de la sécurité
sociale donc les sénateurs qui sont en
train de voter par scrutin public ça
veut dire que chaque vote de chaque
sénateur sera rendu public notamment sur
le site internet du Sénat le vote qui
est en train d'être finalisé et les
résultats à adopter
et donc le Sénat a adopté ce CDI senior
pour favoriser l'emploi des seniors et
justement pour en parler on va retrouver
Quentin calmer en tribune de presse de
l'hémicycle du Sénat Quentin vous avez
suivi avec attention ces débats ce matin
des débats de haute qualité sur ce sujet
du CDI senior quelles ont été à les
temps forts et les différentes positions
autour de cette proposition vous le
disiez Alexandre c'est une mesure portée
par la droite sénatoriale René Paul
Savary leur à partir de la branche
vieillesse du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale ici
au Sénat une mesure donc qui n'avait pas
été examinée par les députés lors de
leur lecture à l'Assemblée nationale la
droite qui est le centre qui propose
donc un CDI senior calqué sur le
principe d'un CDI de chantier pour une
mission de fin de carrière de
l'entreprise un CDI qui vient donc
d'être adopté un rajouter au projet de
loi de réforme des retraites pour leur
apporteur LR il s'agit de par exemple
faire du tutorat dans l'entreprise avec
donc des exonérations de cotisations
familles écouter René PA
on constate que il y a effectivement un
taux de chômage aux alentours de la
soixantaine qui est particulièrement
important c'est pour ça qu'on veut se
doter d'outils nouveaux pour inciter
pour inciter l'employeur nous proposer
une exonération de cotisation familiale
de façon à ce qu'il y ait une incitation
à aller plutôt sur ce CDI très
spécifique négocié avec le salarié par
rapport à traditionnel et pour le
salarié ça me paraît intéressant puisque
on adapte les conditions de travail en
fonction effectivement de son âge ou des
phénomènes d'usure c'est la raison pour
laquelle ce CDI peut être dès à présent
me semble-t-il inscrit dans la loi et je
ne vous demande de le soutenir voilà ce
CDI qui a donc été adopté par le snail
il y a quelques secondes il pourra
concerner les seigneurs à partir de 60
ans on a entendu les centristes à un
moment par la voix d'Olivier non tentée
de demander à ce que par exemple les
salariés des 57 ans soient concernés
finalement ces amendements là indécent
triste ont été retirés la gauche est
extrêmement sceptique c'est le moins que
l'on puisse dire sur cette mesure elle a
voté contre dans l'hémistique mais donc
n'a pas remporté ce vote Monique Lubin a
ainsi dit pour les socialistes cela nous
paraît être un outil pour recruter des
gens que finalement on garde le moins
possible même chose pour Bernard Jomy
qui s'est opposé lui aussi pour les
socialistes en disant ces exonérations
de cotisations familles elles n'ont pas
de sens il faut maintenir ses
cotisations qui financent notre modèle
social écouter pour les communistes
Fabien gay
quand on a reporté l'âge légal de 60 à
62 ans ça a été nul sur l'embauche des
seniors qui n'était pas au travail nul
et donc les 1 million quatre de
personnes qui sont entre 53 et 69 ans
qui sont aujourd'hui sans emploi ni
revenus il y aura pas plus d'embauche
avec ce contrat dernier embauche et le
gouvernement de son côté était également
opposé à cette mesure pour de multiples
raisons mais par exemple et bien Gabriel
Attal a dit que s'il y avait des dangers
avec des effets de seuil avec cet âge à
60 ans ou ce CDI senior serait possible
le risque c'est qu'on décale le problème
aux gens juste avant 60 ans écoutez le
ministre des comptes publics
moi je suis toujours assez sceptique sur
des propositions d'allègement de
cotisations ciblées sur un âge donné le
risque c'est qu'on décale le problème et
que c'est que des personnes qui
aujourd'hui en plus 60 ans et sont au
chômage en fait on décale le problème à
ceux qui sont juste avant 60 ans parce
que eux n'auront pas droit à
l'exonération pour leur employeur s'ils
sont recrutés ça c'est la première chose
sur la deuxième chose c'est un
amendement qui coûte effectivement
une certaine somme voilà et le ministre
également de dénoncer le coût de la
mesure qui est chiffré à 800 millions
d'euros voilà Alex ce CDI senior qui
vient donc d'être adopté 200 de voix
pour 123 voies contre par le Sénat merci
beaucoup Quentin et on va tout de suite
et bien continuer à suivre les débats
sur la réforme des retraites dans
l'hémicycle du Sénat il y a certainement
des choses à regarder et à pousser qui
peuvent être travaillés différemment
d'abord avec des outils d'accompagnement
du mentorat nous avons un plan alors il
y a souvent des
qu'on articule autour d'un jeune une
solution sur rapporteur proposé hier de
dire un seigneur une solution mais nous
avons aussi un plan sur le mentorat qui
nous permet de passer de 20 000
opérations de mon temps à par an et de
20000 jeunes mentorés à 200000 et cette
montée en charge nous y arrivons sans
qu'il est nécessité de mettre en place
un contrat particulier pour inciter au
mentorat il y a une deuxième raison qui
en fait qu'un peu plus loin dans le
texte nous aurons l'occasion d'examiner
ce que nous proposons en matière de
retraite progressive indépendamment des
quelques différences de d'ambition de
perception que nous avons avec la
commission de l'affaire sociale nous
voulons simplifier l'accès à la retraite
progressive et nous considérons que
facilité l'accès à la retraite
progressive pour les employeurs c'est
une manière de diminuer le temps de
travail quand ils ont à leur charge et
donc de faciliter le redéploiement de
ces personnes sur du mentorat et de la
formation donc pour toutes ces raisons
c'est une demande de retrait avec un
perspic la perspective de la loi travail
qui nous permettra d'avancer mais je le
répète la montée en puissance du
mentorat nous y arrivons sans contrat
donc travaillons ensemble pour faire en
sorte que ce soit encore plus effectives
madame de chaîne
oui merci monsieur le Président au vu de
vous explications monsieur le ministre
je veux je vais retirer cet amendement
mais quand même ça favorise l'esprit
d'entreprise la transmission des
savoir-faire ça me semble
particulièrement important et je serai
attentive au moment d'une loi travail
pour que ce dispositif puisse être
amélioré et repris il est retiré un
amendement qui porte le numéro 42
qui le reprend
madame Lindman
parce que ce débat mérite d'être d'être
engagé on passe notre temps à nous
expliquer que la seule façon pour que
dans le travail dans l'entreprise parce
que ça va nous ramener au retraite quand
la seule façon dans l'entreprise c'est
de donner des allègements de cotisation
pour faire ce qui est toujours fait
normalement dans une entreprise c'est à
dire que les plus anciens les plus
compétents au konja qui des compétences
les transmettent aux autres et c'est
bien le débat s'il y a une telle
pression sur les salariés si elle est
salarié sont devenus de moins en moins
des acteurs d'une communauté humaine qui
est l'entreprise maintenant tout le
monde est sous pression sous tension n'a
pas le temps de faire vivre cette
transmissions d'incompétence et on croit
qu'avec un allègement de cotisation on
va pouvoir régler ce problème un ça va
être des effets d'aubaine deux ça
n'amélior era pas le mentorat qui doit
être fondé sur un certain volontarré
volontariat et donc pour ma part je suis
totalement opposé à cet amendement et
puisque je l'ai repris je le retire il
est retiré bon donc
on cesse de jouer avec ça et nous
poursuivons par l'examen du l'amendement
4260 rectifiée
excusez-nous monsieur le Président
qui avait de la concurrence mais je suis
ravi
nous souhaitons par cet amendement
augmenter la pénalité financière des
entreprises qui ne respectent pas leur
obligation en matière d'égalité
professionnelle et notamment en matière
des cas entre de rémunération entre les
hommes et les femmes chacun le sait ici
les inégalités que les femmes subissent
au travail se répercutent sur leurs
droits à la retraite et de statistiques
en rapport le constat est sans appel les
inégalités perdure durant la période
d'activité au point et se répercute je
viens de le dire sur la retraite au
point que le taux de pauvreté des femmes
retraitées et supérieures à celui des
hommes 10,4 pour combien de se jouer
dans l'hémicycle la droite notamment par
l'amendement de Madame de scène
proposait de créer un contrat de
mentorat qui donc serait aligné sur lui
et du CDI senior mais pour favoriser le
mentorat la gauche et donc la sénatrice
a retiré son amendement la gauche a
décidé de le reprendre ce qui est permis
par le Règlement du Sénat quelque chose
qui n'existe pas par rapport à son
nationale lorsque un sénateur décide de
retirer son amendement un autre sénateur
peut décider de le reprendre et donc
Madame Lindman a repris cette amendement
mais pour le dénoncer à ce moment-là et
donc le retirer à nouveau ce qui avait
lu ses applaudissements de la gauche à
ce moment là
c'est contraire représente aujourd'hui
19% des emplois contre 10 il y a 30 ans
donc nous voulons mettre fin à ces
inégalités qui se répercutent sur la
retraite
d'autant que c'est contrats à temps
partiel
accroissent la pression sur chacune ou
chacun des salariés qu'il exerce puisque
bien souvent ça se traduit par faire
plus de travail en moins de temps qu'un
temps complet le permettrait et donc ça
use davantage et donc c'est un double
effet négatif sur les retraites et ça
rend encore plus excès inacceptable le
recul de l'âge de départ de deux ans je
vous remercie je vais demander l'avis de
la commission et la vie du gouvernement
je signale que je suis de saisie d'une
demande de scrutin public par le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen oui merci
effectivement
vous proposez
d'accroître les pénalités en ce qui
concerne cette index il n'était pas
publié pas évolutif dans une période de
trois ans mais vous pouvez proposer à la
fois d'augmenter les pénalités et de
réduire le délai à un an de mise en
conformité en tout cas en l'absence
d'action significative pour faire en
sorte d'améliorer l'inégalité entre les
hommes et les femmes c'est notre
réflexion en ce qui concerne la
commission des affaires sociales à plus
haut penser que il existait déjà des
bases légales très précises en ce qui
concerne l'index homme-femme
contrairement à l'index le senior et en
conséquence nous pensons que ce n'est
pas nécessaire appliquons déjà le
dispositif actuel impliquant les
pénalités si besoin et laissons trois
ans pour se mettre en conformité et là
si c'est pas mis en conformité
effectivement peut être accroître les
pénalités merci merci monsieur le
ministre de vous être emparé de ce donc
nous avons laissé lancer à la commission
des affaires sociales à faire un plan
similaire c'était un jeune une solution
ça apportait ses fruits ça a changé un
petit peu la vision par rapport aux
emplois des jeunes c'est significatif
mais écoutez on pourrait essayer de
décliner à la bourre au moment de la fin
de carrière ce passage entre la partie
active et la sédentarité à travers
effectivement des dispositions madame
liemann qui permettrait à travers un CDI
senior de faire du tutorat à améliorer
bien entendu mais faire du tutorat et
faire véritablement un seigneur une
solution si tout le monde s'empare du
dispositif et bien on aura servi à
quelque chose Monsieur le Ministre
merci monsieur le Président c'est une
demande de retrait ou à vous suivez en
direct le débat entre les sénateurs sur
cette réforme des retraites et pour en
parler j'accueille sur ce plateau Fabien
guerre bonjour bonjour vous êtes
sénateur communiste de Seine-Saint-Denis
à la droite il y a quelques minutes la
droite et le centre du Sénat viennent de
voter ce qu'ils appellent le CDI senior
c'est à dire un contrat pour inciter à
les entreprises à embaucher plus de
seniors notamment à partir de 60 ans
pourquoi cette opposition de la gauche
dans ce débat alors que c'est plutôt une
mesure pour favoriser l'emploi non ça
favorisera pas du tout l'emploi vous
savez ça m'a rappelé mon engagement en
politique en 2006 je manifesté avec des
millions de de personnes et beaucoup de
jeunes contre le contrat premier
embauche qui était déjà destiné à
embaucher les jeunes avec des
exonérations massives de cotisations
sociales c'est exactement la même chose
c'est un contrat dernière embauche qu'on
nous propose avec des exonérations de
cotisations une nouvelle fois qui ne
fonctionne pas j'ai rappelé d'ailleurs
dans l'hémicycle le rapport sur le cice
vous le savez c'est 20 milliards d'euros
de cotisations on nous promettait avec
François Hollande oui avec un badge vous
rappelez pierre Gattaz 1 million
d'emplois ça crée 100000 emplois ça fait
cher quand même pour 18 milliards chaque
année c'est 180000 € de subventions à
l'emploi quand le salaire médian et aux
alentours chargé de cotisation 33000
vous voyez donc ça ne marche pas on sait
que les exonérations pas besoin de
démultiplier les CDI les CDD les
contrats dernière embauche si on veut
agir sur l'emploi alors il y a besoin de
d'agir avec les entreprises et les
contraintes par la loi vous n'y
arriverez pas avec des exonérations
massives ça ne fonctionne pas et
d'ailleurs la dernière chose c'est que
le ministrateur a eu raison on va signer
là aussi la branche famille de la
sécurité sociale c'est 3 à 4 milliards
d'euros de côté d'exonération de
cotisations qui va compenser l'État
milliards à trouver sur cinq ans
peut-être que sur les cinq premières
années l'état exonération et après on
pensera pardon et après donc c'est une
très mauvaise mesure elle ne fonctionne
pas elle a prouvé son inefficacité et en
plus vous allez encore mettre un coup
terrible à la sécurité sociale Fabien on
va parler de la journée de demain le 7
mars avec cet appel à
des syndicats des syndicats qui veulent
je cite mettre la France à l'arrêt
beaucoup de grève dans tout le pays et
puis ici au Sénat ce sera normalement
avec un accord entre les différents
groupes politiques et bien ce sera le
moment de débattre de l'article 7 de la
référence de retraite on verra on verra
mais c'est ce qu'il se dit en tout cas
en tout cas de débattre de l'article 7
sur le report de l'âge légal de départ à
64 ans ce serait important justement que
les sénateurs à débattent de cet article
7 demain demain soir après une
prestation nous nous toujours dit depuis
le début il faut en venir au vote sur
l'article 7 d'abord le débat et que
chacun il n'y a pas une bonne nouvelle
position mais que chacun puisse par un
vote signifie si il veut reporter l'âge
légal de 62 à 64 ans vous le savez pour
le groupe communiste républicain citoyen
écologistes et non et donc demain nous
on est ravis de cette journée on sera un
pied dans la rue aux côtés du mouvement
social un pied dans l'hémicycle
évidemment pour continuer à combattre ce
projet de contre-réforme mais oui il
faut en venir à l'article 7 on verra si
c'est demain on verra si c'est mercredi
on verra si c'est peut-être jeudi peu
importe nous on ne fait pas
d'obstructures la seule obstruction
qu'il y a ici c'est une obstruction
silencieuse de la part de la droite qui
ne refuse de débattre nous on avance et
on en viendra l'article 7 quand ça sera
le temps mais il faudrait que la gauche
peut-être retire certains amendements
pour arriver demain plus vite il
faudrait surtout que la droite arrête
cette obstruction silencieuse et
débattre parce que pour un débat
monsieur Poussard x 2 vous débattez tout
seul et que je réponds aucune question
il y a pas d'interview mais voyez un
débat parlementaire c'est pareil il faut
être deux donc la gauche elle elle agit
tranquillement on avance un certain
nombre d'arguments je crois que depuis
le début personne peut dire qu'il y a eu
des arguments un peu un peu fou on
avance et il faut que la droite débatte
avec nous que les ministres répondent et
puis on est en arrivera tranquillement
l'article 7 qu'est-ce que vous attendez
de cette journée de manifestation et de
grève demain c'est au début du blocage
du pays ah ben écoutez beaucoup et je
sais que ça va être énorme on le voit
partout dans les grandes villes dans les
villages dans les sous-préfecture
partout sur le territoire des dizaines
des centaines de points sont annoncés de
de manifestations la grève va être
massive dans les transports EDF je tiens
les saluer ils ont commencé des week-end
à reprendre leur routier industriel en
main dans le privé dans le public un
certain nombre de collectivités seront
fermés parce que tous les fonctionnaires
seront en grève et il faut que les
mobilisations et les manifestations sont
le plus massif bon mais nous ça va nous
donner du bon moqueur et je vous je vous
av oue qu'on attend le 7 avec très
grande impatience je suis pas sûr que
les ministres ou la droite c'est
notoriale soit dans le même état
d'esprit nous on est très heureux mais
ça donnera du baume au coeur à la gauche
pour les débats demain sur l'article 7
le report de l'âge légal de départ à 64
ans et ce sera à suivre et bien en
direct sur Public Sénat et on retourne
dans l'hémicycle ou les sénateurs
continuent à débattre de cette réforme
des retraites dans ce genre de situation
merci
merci merci monsieur le Président donc
si je partage le constat qui a été fait
sur les bancs jusqu'à l'instant je
partage pas la position sur la
demandement oui aujourd'hui il y a des
inégalités salariales oui il y a des
inégalités de carrière oui nous avons
tenté de diminuer ces inégalités à
travers différents textes et notamment
la proposition de loi que nous qui est
devenue loi sur l'égalité économique et
professionnelle donc il y a des outils
mais on ne va pas réussir à finalement
corriger toutes ces inégalités dont font
l'objet à des femmes à travers un projet
de loi sur les retraites c'est en
réalité on utilise un projet de loi sur
les retraites pour corriger des
carrières or les carrières et bien c'est
évidemment une loi travail c'est
évidemment des propositions à faire sur
sur la réglementation sur
l'accompagnement des femmes et des
parcours de femmes donc oui pour le
constat non pour le vote sur l'amende
ment je vous remercie
je pense merci monsieur le Président je
pense précisément qu'une réforme des
retraites juste devrait se donner pour
priorité de corriger les inégalités en
matière de différence quand même
extrêmement important de retraite entre
les hommes et les femmes et je le redis
c'est différent elle s'explique par les
carrières et les emplois qui sont
occupés par les uns et par les autres
prenons les aesh et je sais madame la
présente de la délégation que vous
connaissez bien le sujet ce sont ah je
crois 90% des femmes avec des contrats
qui sont souvent de moins de 24 heures
semaine avec des salaires qui
n'atteignent même pas les 900 euros si
je prends des caissières de supermarché
elles ont elles aussi souvent des
contrats à temps extrêmement partiels si
on prend les salariés qui travaillent
dans tout le secteur de l'entretien avec
des amplitudes horaires phénoménales
et bien je pense qu'il faut que nous
soyons plus volontariste et que les
outils que nous développons soient
beaucoup plus ferme pour corriger cela
parce que vous savez il y a de multiples
choses qui mettent les gens dans la rue
en ce moment et certains ont nous ont
fait l'honneur de croire que nous en
étions quasiment les uniques
responsables mais une des premières
choses qui a mis des gens dans la rue
est particulièrement des femmes c'est la
non-volté de corriger ces inégalités il
y a énormément de femmes dans les
cortèges et je pense que chacun serait
bien intentionné de les écouter il n'y a
pas de recette miracle et effectivement
les dispositifs vont mettre du temps à
faire leur effet mais si on se dit bon
bah les choses avancent après tout ça
fera son effet le moment viendra ou
enfin l'égalité sera là je crois qu'on
est vraiment en dessous de la réalité de
l'aspiration des femmes
oui merci monsieur le Président moi il y
a quelque chose qui m'étonne toujours y
compris dans cette émission c'est quand
des collègues ou des ministres au bord
du gouvernement nous disent mais ça
commence à faire effet on est en 2023 il
y a toujours pas d'égalité
professionnelle malgré les nombreuses
lois qui ont été votées il y a pas
d'amélioration réelle des conditions de
travail et pas non plus des conditions
de retraite et messieurs les ministres
avec votre réforme vous allez encore
aggraver les choses vous allez aggraver
les choses et à tel point d'ailleurs que
toutes les associations féministes tous
les syndicats sont vend debout sur cette
réforme et particulièrement sur le sort
qui est réservé aux femmes quand on ne
prend pas en compte le fait que ce sont
elles et ça a été dit par mes collègues
qui ont des carrières hachées qui ont
une pénibilité dans de nombreux métiers
maximum on parle effectivement des des
travailleuses et des travailleurs
première de corvées lors notamment de la
covid on les a applaudis au gouvernement
aussi vous les avez applaudis mais ça a
été quoi après les conséquences qui ont
été tirées pour améliorer les choses
aucune et quand vous osez prendre comme
référence l'index sur l'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes pour essayer
hier de nous faire passer la pilule sur
l'index des seniors c'est quand même de
l'enfumage pourquoi c'est de l'enfumage
parce que l'index pour l'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes et totalement
insuffisant et vous ne nous écoutez pas
vous ne nous entendez pas vous refusez
de nous entendre ici dans l'hémicycle
mais aussi dans la rue et c'est pourquoi
d'ailleurs demain la mobilisation va
être extrêmement forte et c'est une
bonne nouvelle pour tout le monde c'est
une bonne nouvelle parce que ça va
peut-être faire bouger les choses mais
là encore vous préférez dialoguer entre
vous plutôt que d'entendre la
représentation parlementaire
outre la situation des femmes sur la
réforme des retraites au Sénat on va
retrouver Quentin Calmet dans la tribune
de l'hémicycle Quentin on va faire avec
vous un petit point de du suivi de ces
débats ce matin on en est où exactement
alors effectivement le CDI senior voulut
par la droite et le centralité adopté
donc maintenant on est dans une série
d'amendements vous lui par la gauche de
l'hémicycle notamment en examine en ce
moment un amendement communiste qui vise
et bien augmenter la pénalité financière
des entreprises qui ne respectent pas
leurs obligations en matière d'égalité
professionnelle notamment en cycose
concerne les écarts de rémunération et
en particulier entre les hommes et les
femmes donc on voit toute une série
d'amendements voulu par la gauche autour
de ces écarts de rémunération en
entreprise et je vous le signal il y
aura un scrutin public dans les
prochaines minutes sur cet abonnement
vous lui parlez communiste Alex merci
beaucoup Quentin scrutin public ça veut
dire que chaque sénateur va voter sur sa
tablette sur sa tablette électronique et
que le vote des sénateur sera rendu
public allez on retourne dans
l'hémicycle on en a pour je ne sais
combien de siècles pour régler le
problème mais madame billon oui c'est un
problème de recettes parce que vous vous
nous expliquez qu'on est obligé de
travailler jusqu'à 60 cavalages égal à
64 parce que globalement on a un trou
dans la on aurait un déficit mais il
aurait pas de difficile si le niveau des
salaires étaient meilleurs si niveau des
salaires des femmes étaient égales à
celui des hommes il y aurait pas de
difficile si si vous vous payez
correctement les métiers d'ailleurs dans
la simulation qui a été faite sur les
sur les retraites il a été prévu que
dans la fonction publique ni embauche et
gel du point d'indice or les femmes les
infirmières les professeurs le nombre
important de femmes dans les
collectivités locales vous n'allez pas
augmenter leur salaire vous n'allez pas
revaloriser leur métier et vous allez
encaisser les caisses de retraite et
nous faire travailler ou de la 64 ans
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
les ministres mes chers collègues on
sait que la retraite c'est le refret de
la vie à la fois de des inégalités de la
vie mais aussi peut-être des promesses
ou en tout cas de ce qui n'a pas pu être
tenu dans une vie et je trouve que ce
débat que nous avons aujourd'hui
en tout cas par l'amendement que je
salue de Madame Brulin et est
intéressant parce que finalement à
celles et ceux qui disent mais ne vous
inquiétez pas ça avance finalement on va
réussir aujourd'hui en 2023 cet écart de
40% est absolument énorme
on ne peut pas s'en satisfaire et on le
sait bien alors pourquoi refuser des
dispositifs qui vont permettre de
contraindre un peu plus ou en tout cas
de faire pousser un peu plus ces
inégalités je trouve que aujourd'hui
quand on parle des femmes et Madame
Brulin l'a dit on sait que le taux de
pauvreté est plus élevé 10,4% pour les
une femme quand il n'est que de 8,5%
pour les hommes et un dernier chiffre
qui est imparable c'est que les cas
entre le taux de pauvreté moyen des
femmes et des hommes retraités a
tendance oui mes chers collègues à se
creuser depuis 2012 puisque aujourd'hui
nous sommes à 1,9 points en 2019 alors
qu'il n'était que de 0,6 points en 2012
donc vraiment je trouve que c'est
important et je voterai cette amendement
bien nous allons procéder
au scrutin public
le scrutin est ouvert
sont donc en train de voter sur une
proposition d'amendements de la gauche
d'imposer des pénalités financières aux
entreprises qui ne respecteraient pas
l'égalité de rémunération entre les
hommes et les femmes l'égalité de
rémunération professionnelle en
amendement défendu sur tous les bancs
des groupes politiques de gauche on a
entendu les communistes les socialistes
défendre cette mesure restrictive pour
les entreprises pour essayer de
favoriser l'égalité salariale entre les
femmes et les hommes on est donc dans un
scrutin public ça veut dire que chaque
sénateur est en train de voter sur sa
tablette électronique et qu'au final son
vote sur cet amendement concernant
l'égalité salariale entre les femmes et
les hommes sont votes sera rendu public
voilà pour cette matinée ici au Sénat le
vote est clos on va entendre le résultat
alors que résultat votre 144 supprimer
pour 91 contre 241 de Sénat n'a pas
adopté et nous passons
un amendement
3219 madame pensé Monge le présente il y
a un certain amendement qui vont faire
l'objet d'une discussion commune merci
monsieur le Président Henri il s'agit
par cet amendement
d'obliger les entreprises à publier des
indicateurs relatifs à la continuité des
carrières si vous voulez un poursuite
des parcours professionnels sans rupture
en effet les personnes ayant des
carrières hachées sont pénalisés
notamment lors de leur départ à la
retraite et la présente loi ici agraps
phénomène par l'accélération de la durée
requise pour avoir un temps plein et oui
monsieur le rapporteur ce qui est d'une
brutalité inédite c'est bien la synergie
des deux paramètres c'est à dire des
mesures d'âge et là c'est toujours la
droite qui les a voté et aussi
effectivement de la durée requise donc
qui appartient un certes à Madame
Touraine mais l'accélération c'est vous
selon
l'adresse je dirais pour mieux
comprendre d'ailleurs cela c'est qu'il y
a une personne qui est commune
à ces deux assez de vote c'est quand
même monsieur Macron qui était déjà dans
l'équipe qu'il avait très bien selon
l'adresse 32 % des retraités de la
génération 50 ont une carrière
incomplète alors il est normal que les
personnes ayant des carrières hachées
perçoivent des retraites plus faibles
enfin c'est pas que c'est normal c'est
que c'est c'est logique en 2016 les
carrières incomplètes représentent 60%
des personnes qui bénéficient d'un
minimum de pension du régime général
les carrières hachées brisent de
nombreuses femmes à liquider tardivement
leurs droits à la retraite et les oblige
à poursuivre jusqu'à 67 ans elles sont
20% contre 10% des hommes âge de la fin
de l'application de la décote et cela ne
les préserve pas pour autant d'une
retraite faible c'est simplement la
double peine qui s'arrête à 67 ans
l'amendement 25 23 monsieur le Président
Gantin oui merci monsieur le Président
c'est amendement instaure dans toutes
les entreprises depuis 300 salariés des
indicateurs de continuité de carrière
ces indicateurs et leurs méthodes de
calcul sont définies par décret peuvent
être complétés par convention par accord
de branche l'amendement prévoit enfin
des pénalités financières pour les
entreprises qui ne respecteraient pas
ces obligations ces indicateurs en plus
plusieurs objectifs le premier renforcer
la prise de conscience des entreprises
sur le fléau que représente les
carrières hachées subies et les inciter
donc à faire des efforts assurer la
transparence des pratiques de chaque
entreprise auprès des partenaires
sociaux des administrations d'État et du
public octroyez au pouvoir public les
données précieuses leur permettant
d'agir en conséquence les carrières
hachées touchent majoritairement des
femmes exerçant dans des métiers
pénibles les temps partiels sont souvent
imposées aux femmes dans des métiers
précaires et le texte ne s'attaque
absolument pas à ce phénomène or notre
système de retraite est pensé sur le
modèle des carrières des hommes le
retrait de son calcul et deux facteurs
salaires et durée de Carrière Or les
femmes ont des carrières plus courtes ou
des salaires plus faibles que c'est des
hommes les différentes études le
montrent les femmes se retirent souvent
de l'emploi pour prendre en charge les
enfants ou pour prendre soin d'un parent
malade ou dépendant une femme sur deux
réduit ou arrête complètement son
activité professionnelle à l'arrivée
d'un enfant c'est le cas d'un homme sur
neuf résultat les femmes entre 25 et 54
ans ont un taux d'activité de 8 points
inférieurs à celui des hommes 84% contre
92%. cumuler aux inégalités salaires la
conséquence des carrières hachées et
triple des pensions plus faibles le
montant des pensions de droit direct est
inférieurs de 40% à celui versé aux
hommes même après le versement de la
pension réversion les femmes perçoivent
une pension inférieure de 28% à celle
des hommes par ailleurs 37% des femmes
de retraite touche moins de 1000 euros
de pension brut
un taux plein difficilement atteint seul
60% des femmes partent à la retraite à
taux plein contre 68% des hommes des
départs plus tardifs à la retraite en
moyenne 6 mois plus tard
bouger les choses merci l'amendement
suivant qui le présente Madame Pons
monsieur Boyer
non je sens que vous êtes en concurrence
un petit doute parce que
beaucoup de choses que je voulais dire
ont été dites donc je vais essayer de
dire ce qui n'a pas été dit alors
effectivement c'est ce sont des
amendements relatifs à l'impact des
carrières hachées qui touche ça a été
dit ça par contre majoritairement les
femmes et je jouerai peut-être que c'est
par construction sociale et non de façon
innée mais pas construction sociale les
femmes effectivement sont renvoyées au
métier du prendre soin les femmes se
retirent souvent de l'emploi pour
prendre en charge les enfants ou pour
prendre en charge un parent malade ou
dépendant les aidants les fameuses
aidants qui vont faire l'objet de
d'un amendement
sont Ess entiellement des femmes
et une femme sur deux réduit arrête
complètement son activité
professionnelle ou arrête professionnel
à l'arrivée d'un enfant c'est le cas
d'un homme seulement sur neuf et ils en
profite pour dire qu'il faudra
accompagner une évolution sociale quand
même un peu trop lente on va pas
attendre trois siècles quand même que
pour que les femmes soient moins comme
ça assignés aux tâches du prendre soin
donc il faudra accompagner cette
évolution sociétale avec d'autres
réformes et nous vous proposerons
notamment plus tard un changement
législatif sur le congé paternel
post-natal qui soit allongé parce que
c'est peut-être à ce moment là que les
comportements y compris tout au long de
la vie pour s'occuper après de quelqu'un
de malade ou de quelqu'un d'une personne
âgée en perte d'autonomie si dès le
départ dès le la naissance le congé
paternel post natal c'est fini alors
voilà j'ai dit des choses différentes je
vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
monsieur broyer
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur des ministres
collègues cet amendement déposé par mon
collègue dessus n'est pas concurrent il
a effectivement totalement
complémentaire et cohérent avec ceux qui
viennent défendus pour les femmes c'est
effectivement la triple peine inégalité
salariale inégalité des pensions
inégalités du temps de travail et les
chiffres en témoignent ils sont
dramatiques à l'heure actuelle une femme
sur cinq est contrainte de travailler
jusqu'à 67 ans pour bénéficier d'une
retraite à taux plein contre un homme
sur dix les carrières des femmes sont
généralement hachées et c'est la raison
de cet amendement d'appel parce qu'elles
sont socialisées au travail du Caire
lorsqu’un de leurs parents devient
malade ou dépendant lorsqu'elles ont un
enfant les femmes sont celles qui en
général quittent leur emploi et
travaillent à temps partiel et c'est
inégalité ne doit pas perdurer dans le
temps force est de constater que la
réforme n'améliore pas cette situation
des femmes peut-être d'ailleurs parce
que encore une fois le gouvernement
choisi un véhicule un juste et
inapproprié un petit véhicule législatif
d'une loi de finance rectificative pour
parler d'un énorme problème qui est
celui du travail et de la retraite mais
on retombe toujours sur les visions
alors mon collègue évoquait la situation
d'une personne je donne pas son nom 55
ans mais en 68 elle a passé 8 ans sans
travailler pour élever ses quatre
enfants et a commencé à travailler à 20
ans avant la réforme ces 8 années sans
travailler étaient compensés par les 8
trimestres donnés par enfant pour les
enfants et par le congé parental elle
pouvait donc partir à 62 ans après la
réforme elle devra attendre 64 ans pour
partir à la retraite et elle perd la
surcote de 7 et demi pour cent dont elle
aurait bénéficié en travaillant jusqu'à
64 ans autre problème les temps partiels
souvent imposés dans les métiers
précaires ne sont pas du tout pris en
compte dans ce texte pour toute cette
raison nous demandons au gouvernement de
revoir sa copie
je présente l'amendement 3500 si vous
nous rejoignez sur l'antenne de Public
Sénat nous sommes lundi au cinquième
jour de l'examen de la réforme des
retraites au Sénat et à l'instant nous
venons de passer sous la barre des 3000
amendements qu'il reste à examiner d'ici
au 12 mars au Sénat de quoi parle-t-on
lorsque l'on parle de ces amendements et
bien en fait le gouvernement dépose un
projet de loi donc une réforme en
l'occurrence la réforme des retraites
qui prend ici et bien la forme d'un
projet de loi de financement
rectificatif de la sécurité sociale le
PLFSS r dont on parle depuis le début de
l'examen et bien à cette loi à ce projet
de loi elle vient s'ajoute viennent
s'ajouter des amendements donc déposer
par les sénateurs il y en avait au total
plus de 4700 certains ont été jugés
irrecevables car ils ne portait pas sur
une loi de financement la sécurité
sociale il y en avait au total 3700 au
début de l'examen et donc on vient de
passer sous la barre des 3000 j'ai en
même temps
synergie on l'a dit la durée requise
c'est vrai en général la durée requise
de cotisation tous de façon
différentielle tout le monde bien sûr
mais et plus et en général très
impactante pour les femmes à cause
justement de ces carrières hachées les
mesures d'allongement de l'âge
d'ouverture du droit à la retraite
touche en général tout le monde mais
plus particulièrement les catégories
socioprofessionnelles ouvriers employés
qualifiés ou non qualifiés
d'ailleurs est-ce que je voudrais dire
c'est que la synergie et bien
effectivement c'est les ouvrières les
employés femmes dans les métiers de
service qui elle en tant que femme si
vous voulez cette synergie vraiment
impact plus particulièrement nous en
reparlerons le 8 mars pour dire que
cette réforme
pour voilà pour dire que cette réforme
est une réforme quand le monde du
travail mais aussi contre les femmes
bien
dans le passé a demandé l'avis du de la
Commission à la vie du gouvernement je
vous l'ai signaler que je suis saisi de
deux demandes de scrutin public sur les
deux premiers amendements
oui merci monsieur le Président
je suis surpris de voir comme vous
devenez des adeptes de l'intex Senior et
des index en général
voyez-vous moi j'avais dit que j'étais
pas fan des index je vous l'ai dit dès
le départ bon à la rigueur l'index au
Seigneur mais j'irai pas plus loin dans
dans les index voyez-vous et surtout
pour parler des carrières hachées je
pense que c'est pas un index qu'il faut
c'est les valoriser voyez je serai
plutôt sur le label pour les carrières
hachées plutôt que sur les index mais ça
permet de rappeler un certain nombre de
choses parce que vous avez dénoncé à
juste titre mais ça a été dénoncé aussi
sur les bancs de la droite les
inégalités de carrière
effectivement c'est au cours de la
carrière professionnelle qu'il y a de
nombreux inégalités et elle se
traduisent après au moment de la
retraite c'est incontournable je vous
rappelle à ce propos là que c'est un
système par point les corrige pas
elles sont peut-être plus corrigées un
système paranuité que par un système par
point preuve en est c'est que les
agriculteurs nous ont demandé qu'on
calcule leur pension qui était sur un
système à points par des annuités ce qui
montre bien que les réformes de retraite
quelle qu'elle soit il y a tellement
d'inégalités sur le plan salarial sur le
plan des retraites qui se retraduisent
certaines sont gommés je vous rappelle
quand même que les montants de retraite
les différences de montants entre les
plus aisées et les plus pauvres sont
atténués par rapport aux différences de
salaires donc il y a un effet
redistributif à l'intérieur de notre
système paraîtrait à partition qui est
contributif qui gomme certaines
inégalités mais par contre
les différences qu'il a entre régime
peut en accentuer d'autres donc ça nous
a pas échappé qu'il fallait faire
quelque chose pour les carrières hachées
notamment pour les maires de famille
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
proposons un dispositif de surcote à
l'article 8 mes chers collègues
il est important il est important vous
qui êtes attaché à ces inégalités
notamment pour les niveaux de pension
notamment pour la prise en compte des
trimestres des maires de famille il est
important que nous puissions aller
jusque l'article 8 de faire en sorte que
quelque part dans nos débats on arrive à
s'entendre mais gagner un peu de temps
quand même parce que nos consignes rien
ont besoin qu'on amène
un peu plus de justice sociale au niveau
de cette réforme notamment avec les
maires de famille et ça peut être une
discussion qui peut les intéresser à ce
niveau là c'est la raison également pour
laquelle
nous avons pensé à travers ce dispositif
de prendre en compte les trimestres de
majoration qui ne seront pas
suffisamment brouillés en compte et je
réponds à Monsieur brolier parce que
dans l'exemple qui nous donne monsieur
Broly
si j'ai bien compris vous parlez d'une
mère de famille de trois enfants ce qui
veut dire cette mère de famille elle a
trois fois huit trimestres de majoration
en ce qui concerne la prise en compte de
ces maternités dans le système privé par
contre elle n'aura que deux trimestres
selon la date de la 4 trimestre puisque
il y a une modification dans le secteur
public là aussi c'est une inégalité
c'est la raison pour laquelle vous
verrez qu'à l'article 8 quand on parle
de la prise en compte des maires de
famille avec des majorations on met à
une majoration voyez-vous on n'a pas mis
un nombre de majorations parce que
justement on entretenait cette
différence entre le public et le privé
qui méritera d'être discuté c'est
rapporté à des travaux du corps compter
sur maudite Lubin et moi-même pour faire
en sorte que les gens Marie voir un
Ulbert qui fait partie du corps pour
faire en sorte qu'on soit attentif à
trouver des solutions parce que nous
considérons que ces particulièrement
inégalitaire et actuellement il y a déjà
dans le système de calcul de pension 20%
de ces majorations qui ne sont pas
prises en compte ces maires de famille
qui pensent que leur majoration veulent
attribuer des points supplémentaires à
la fois pour le calcul de la durée leur
permettant derrière d'éviter parfois un
phénomène de décote ne sont pas pris en
compte à hauteur de 20% dans
l'augmentation de la durée d'âge ça
c'est un effet connexe on n'y peut rien
c'est 30% des majorations qui ne seront
pas prises c'est la raison pour laquelle
ça nous a interpellé que nous proposons
ce dispositif de surcote donc pour
conclure monsieur le Président on peut
pas gommer toutes les inégalités et nous
aurons encore l'un des propositions à
faire dans ce domaine là merci
merci Monsieur le Ministre non très
rapidement monsieur le Président la
question des carrières hachées c'est
évidemment un vrai sujet et c'est vrai
que les carrières hachées se révèlent
encore plus au moment de la retraite
avec des pensions qui sont moins
importantes je suis pas convaincu que
l'outil index soit le mieux adapté pour
répondre à la question des carrières
hachées d'abord parce que si le salarié
est dans l'entreprise c'est bien que
l'entreprise en question permet de
réduire le côté haché de la carrière
puisqu'elle a recruté le salarié et donc
je vois pas c'est un peu bizarre d'aller
pointer du doigt à l'entreprise qui
précisément lui permet aux salariés
d'être dans l'entreprise si c'est sur la
question des contrats courts madame
linman je vous entendais m'interpeller
pour moi la question des contrats courts
elle est traitée en grande partie par le
bonus malus qu'on a mis en place sur les
cotisations des entreprises liées au
recours aux contrats courts ça me semble
beaucoup plus efficace cette mesure là
que l'index donc pour ces raisons
défavorables merci
nous allons passer au vote explication
de vote madame Meunier est inscrite
merci monsieur le Président moi je
voterai les amendements proposés par le
groupe écologiste solidarité et
territoire
ça a été dit triple Pen pour les femmes
et notamment donc les carrières hachées
alors bien sûr l'index c'est pas l'alpha
et l'oméga mais c'est un moyen que l'on
peut avec des critères bien resserrés se
servir pour contraindre ceci dit je sais
que c'est pas la panacée et je vais vous
donner un exemple de ce qui existe dans
l'index et Gap pro et Gap pro donne la
note donc égalité professionnelle entre
les femmes et les hommes donne la note
de 92 sur 100 un groupe hôtelier là on
peut dire bravo quand on y regarde de
près l'indicateur 1 celui qui mesure
l'écart de rémunération entre les femmes
et les hommes par tranche d'âge et
catégories socioprofessionnelles
abaisser passant de 38 40 à 33 sur 40
donc l'écart radio augmenter en défaveur
des femmes mais cette baisse est
compensée par une autre dimension qu'on
trouve à l'indeck à l'indicateur 5 et
qui lui équilibre entre le nombre de
femmes et le nombre d'hommes dans les 10
plus hautes catégories de rémunération
et là donc on peut penser que cette
entreprise a embauché plus de femmes
donc vous voyez comment le diable se
niche dans les détails parce que plus de
femmes mais moins rémunéré et au total
une bonne note donc on peut faire dire
ce que l'on veut aux index et c'est pour
ça qu'on est très méfiant sur les index
seniors en rapprochant et en resserrant
les critères on peut peut-être avoir
plus de garanties
je pense que les index c'est vraiment
pas la la panacée néanmoins j'observe
qu'on veut bien mettre des index sur
certains sujets et pas sur d'autres et
de ce point de vue la précarité du
salariat les carrières hachées c'est
quand même une des grandes crises du
monde du travail aujourd'hui donc comme
Madame chaque fois chers collègues je me
trompe de votre nom c'est pas si tu dois
faire un blocage pensez
le fait cette proposition avec ses
collègues c'est une bonne proposition
parce qu'elle équilibre le regard qu'on
doit avoir sur la situation mais
monsieur le ministre
vous ne faites aucun vous n'avez pas du
tout l'intention de faire des progrès
pour réduire les carrières assez puisque
en tout cas pour les femmes puisque dans
les simulations du corps que vous avez
et les données que vous avez données on
maintient le taux d'activité des femmes
en 2030 excusée du peu à l'actuel taux
d'activités des femmes or le taux
d'activité des femmes il est lié aussi à
la précarité des emplois des femmes pas
simplement d'avoir un emploi c'est de
équivalent en place et je puis dire donc
vous n'avez aucune attention politique
de faire reculer la précarité dans pour
les métiers féminins puisque vous
maintenez le taux d'activité des femmes
enfin monsieur le rapporteur j'adore
votre proposition de dire on va pas
faire des Indes contraignants on va
faire des labels
alors moi j'imagine bien le groupe
Airbus
ayant face à lui plusieurs
sous-traitants pour telle ou tel
activité dire ah ben non finalement
celui-là il est un petit peu plus cher
ou moins cher mais il a quand même un
label Qualité
emploi du Seigneur donc finalement je
vais prendre donc franchement les labels
n'ont pas cette efficacité
monsieur Lecomte
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
collègue je soutiendrai bien entendu
c'est c'est ces amendements même s'ils
ne constitue pas en eux-mêmes des
solutions aux difficultés indiquées
concernant les inégalités salariales en
particulier femme homme et les carrières
hachées toutefois si on veut avancer sur
le plan des résolutions c'est mieux de
les connaître de les chiffrer et de bien
les préciser donc ça son utilité je
regrette aussi que finalement dans cette
réforme même si le débat que nous avons
sur ces points montrent combien il est
important de pouvoir améliorer ces
dispositions à la fois pour permettre
des des meilleures retraites mais aussi
pour mieux favoriser les carrières
longues et les carrières qui permettent
finalement de cotiser à la retraite mais
je voudrais aussi en tant que sénateur
représentant les Français établir de
France parler des carrières Rachel à
l'international
des membres d'un couple qui suivent leur
conjoint et qui se trouvent en situation
d'avoir interrompu leur carrière des
réflexions sur ce sujet existe de la
même manière que dans plusieurs pays
européens vous avez la possibilité soit
pendant votre carrière
soit au moment de la liquidation de
votre retraite de partager ou de
transmettre à votre conjoint des
annuités ou des trimestres cotisés et il
me semble qu'une réflexion dans ce
domaine mais mériterait aussi d'être
pris en compte bien entendu ça ne serait
pas un avantage pour la les cotisations
à l'assurance vieillesse par contre pour
les personnes concernées ça permettrait
de limiter un certain nombre de
personnes qui aujourd'hui se trouvent
avec les guerrières hachées des
handicaps au moment de liquidation de
retraite parce qu'ils ont favorisé la
carrière de leur conjoint et je crois
que c'est quelque chose qui mériterait
d'être fait en tout état que sur tous
ces sujets on voit bien que c'est pas à
la va-vite que nous pouvons résoudre ces
problèmes mais bien dans un vrai projet
de loi de réforme des retraites qui qui
mettrait dans la loi des accords entre
partenaires sociaux monsieur
sur la réforme des retraites ce matin au
sein de la Haute Assemblée les sénateurs
qui sont en train actuellement de
débattre et bien d'une proposition
d'amendements des sénateurs écologistes
pour créer un index sur les carrières
hachées dans les entreprises un index
cariérarchique qui ne fait pas
l'unanimité même à gauche c'est un
socialiste sur un peu sceptique sur la
proposition de leur collègue écologiste
pour parler de ce débat sur la réforme
des retraites au Sénat j'accueille
Philippe mouillé bonjour vous êtes
vice-président du groupe les
républicains en Sénat sénateur des
Deux-Sèvres un mot sur la formation de
la matinée la majorité de droite et du
centre du Sénat à voter ce qu'ils
appellent le CDI senior c'est à dire un
contrat pour inciter les entreprises à
embaucher des salariés de plus de 60 ans
avec une exonération de cotisation
familiale pourquoi selon vous c'est la
bonne solution alors que le gouvernement
n'y est pas favorable alors d'abord nous
on souhaitait surtout apporter une
réponse à la question d'interrogations
regarde de la mise en place de l'annexe
senior l'index étant une information
mais absolument pas un outil adapté
suffisamment adapté c'est juste une
information et donc nous proposons ce
CDI seniors donc rappelons donc l'idée
c'est de permettre à une personne qui va
partir de 60 ans de pouvoir avoir un CDI
qui a une durée jusqu'à ce que ces
personnes-là est la totalité ses droits
à la retraite donc ça peut aller jusqu'à
70 ans quel âge maximum voilà donc
l'idée c'est de pouvoir permettre à
avoir un outil adapté pour faire en
sorte que les charges qui inconce
souvent des niveaux de célèbre plus
élevé puisque lorsqu'on a plein de
carrière soit compensées pour les
entreprises par une exonération des
charges familiales c'est un outil
supplémentaire on croit beaucoup à cette
opportunité il faudra bien entendu
évaluer mais il faut dans tous les cas
agir et répondre alors le gouvernement
nous renvoie ce sujet là à une future
loi travail nous nous pensons que il est
d'actualité en parallèle de l'index en
parallèle de la réforme des retraites de
mettre en place cet outil dans
l'actualité dans le gouvernement dit
attention au coup selon le ministre
Gabriel Attal ça coûterait 800 millions
d'euros par an et ça assécherait
progressivement les finances de la
branche famille de la sécurité sociale
alors avant la droite est plutôt
rigoureuse sur les publics
en parallèle le coût de l'assurance
chômage pour les seniors de plus de 2
milliards donc pour nous on nous sommes
persuadés que nous aurons d'un côté sert
des charges supplémentaires et donc un
impact pour la branche famille mais de
l'autre côté un gain on regarde de de
gain qui est frais sur l'assurance
chômage donc après c'est l'histoire de
transfert de compte mais on est en tous
les cas certains que le bilan global
sera favorable pour les finances
publiques à moins sur la journée demain
Philippe mouillé grande journée de
mobilisation avec des manifestations
partout en France les syndicats qui
appellent à mettre la France à l'arrêt
et dans le même temps les sénateurs vont
continuer de débattre est-ce que vous
confirmez que les sénateurs vont
débattre de l'article 7 sur le report à
64 ans et bien demain alors on va voir
en fonction de l'évolution parce que on
perdue quand même du temps donc pour
l'instant ce n'est pas encore gagné
quand dans les délaisses on garde le
même rythme que nous puissions atteindre
l'article 7 dès demain en tous les cas
on sait que c'est un une envie un
souhait de l'opposition sanatorial de
faire en sorte que on puisse avoir au
calendrier certainement après les
manifestations le débat sur l'article 7
voilà donc on nous verrons bien nous
nous sommes preneurs dans tous les cas
d'un débat le plus rapide que nous
allons le plus rapidement possible à cet
Arcueil 7 de façon à ce que clairement
nous puissions marquer nos positions et
enclencher ensuite les autres articles
du texte de loi voilà donc nous verrons
en fonction de du déroulé de la journée
de cette nuit et si le pays est bloqué
qu'il y a des manifestations records
dans tout le pays est-ce que ça pourrait
influer sur le vote des sénateurs alors
sur le vote des sénateurs je ne pense
pas forcément on regarde ce qui se passe
notamment au niveau national après c'est
une question qui est renvoyée au
gouvernement dans sa capacité à la fois
de discuter du dialoguer de sa méthode
de communication et nous verrons au
regard de ce qui se passe mais nous
sommes nous dans une logique vous
connaissez depuis le début c'est-à-dire
que ça fait 4 ans que nous avons une une
conduite qui est la même donc
aujourd'hui on va pas se déjger au
regard des manifestations même si on
entend le message et on comprend
également cette mobilisation parce que
ces rôles des CDK aussi de réagir au
final vous pensez que le Sénat arrivera
au bout dimanche soir à minuit au bout
de l'examen de cette réforme des
retraites il reste encore 3000
amendements on n'a pas on a passé la
barre des 3000 ce matin oui oui je peux
pas vous répondre on le souhaite sur
tous les cas mais je suis pas certain ça
va vraiment dépendre du rythme voilà
donc à la fois on va voir comment on va
travailler quels sont les plages
horaires ou qui va être ouvertes quels
sont les négociations possibles que sur
les outils aussi que c'était un peu
mettre en place faudra justement
utiliser cette Arsenal réglementaire
pour accélérer les débats on fera le
point mercredi matin mais peut-être
qu'il sera nécessaire sera nécessaire de
le faire dans tous les cas nous
souhaitons nous la majorité sénatoriale
aller au bout du texte un mot peut-être
sur la qualité des débats il y a eu des
débats de très bonne tenue ce matin
alors que peut-être ce weekend on avait
une droite un peu silencieuse face à une
gauche voilà qui était très très polices
ça y est il y a un vrai débat entre la
droite et la gauche au Sénat alors il y
a un vrai débat surtout parce que nous
avons des amendements ce week-end on
avait surtout des abandons de
suppression de la part de l'opposition X
fois le même argument enfin avec on voit
bien une volonté d'obsession par le
volume d'amendement déposé ce matin nous
étions cette fois dans une défense de
nos propos abondements puisque nous
avons proposé la mise en place de ce CDI
senior donc on est dans un débat
différent et quelque part à travers
cette réforme on retrouve un peu le le
gérer le débat gauche-droite sur les
fondamentaux merci beaucoup Philippe
mouiller d'être venu sur notre sur notre
plateau ici dans la salle des
conférences du Sénat on va tout de suite
aller dans la tribune de l'hémicycle
retrouver Quentin Calmet Quentin quels
ont été les temps forts de cette matinée
et bien vous le disiez sans conteste
l'information de la matinée c'est
l'adoption par le Sénat de ce CDI senior
voulut par la majorité de la droite et
du centre je vous redonne le chiffre du
vote 202 pour 123 contre le Sénat adopté
cette mesure qui est une mesure nouvelle
Alex figurer pas dans le texte que les
députés ont examinés puisque c'est un
apport de René Paul Savary un peu le
monsieur retraite du Senna il est
rapporteur de la branche vieillesse du
projet de loi de financement la sécurité
sociale il siège au bord de la
commission il a expliqué explicité ce
qu'il voulait faire avec ce CDI il
s'agit d'un CDI senior calqué sur le
principe des CDI de chantier pour une
mission de fin de carrière dans une
entreprise avec un temps de travail
adapté aussi des missions de tutorat
éventuellement et bien sûr en échange
des exonérations de cotisations famille
pour l'employeur pour encourager
l'entreprise a effectivement salarié
davantage de seniors cette mesure n'a
pas du tout convaincu la gauche écouter
l'accusation du socialistiane
chanterelle et la réponse de René Paul
Savary après écoutez monsieur le
rapporteur Sabari vous aurez dû renommer
votre amendement l'amendement Medef
parce que c'est c'est une commande
directe du Medef cette mesure va dans le
bon sens à déclarer Eric chevet le
vice-président de la CPE on n'est pas
étonné de sa la réaction parce que avec
ce CDI Seigneur vous allez permettre au
patron d'être exonéré des cotisations
familles non je ne suis pas asservie aux
Medef à tel point que j'accepte bien
volontiers l'indicateur je crois pas que
ce soit le Medef qui réclame
l'indicateur mais permettez-moi de vous
dire que
j'ai des relations toujours
respectueuses avec les différents
partenaires sociaux voilà notre très
rapide pour vous dire que le
gouvernement était contre cette mesure
notamment à cause de son coût 800
millions d'euros les débats qui
continuent derrière moi
2998 amendement encore à examiner Alex
merci beaucoup Quentin et donc
l'information de cette matinée c'est que
le Sénat a voté en faveur de la création
d'un CDI à senior avec une exonération
de cotisation familiale notamment pour
favoriser l'embauche des seniors c'est
la fin de cette émission spéciale ce
matin ici en direct du Sénat pour suivre
les débats sur la réforme des retraites
je vous donne rendez-vous à 14h30 pour
la suite des débats ce sera en direct
sur Public Sénat et puis également à
suivre sur publicena.fr très bonne
journée sur Public Sénat
[Musique]
les questions au Gouvernement c'est le
temps fort de la semaine au Sénat chaque
mercredi les sénateurs interpellent les
ministres dans l'hémicycle on vous fait
suivre cette séance en direct et en
exclusivité et avancer on se retrouve en
plateau pour débattre des grands thèmes
du moment et après la séance on débriefs
avec nos journalistes aux quatre coins
du Sénat et de nombreux invités
rendez-vous mercredi à 14h sur Public
Sénat
[Musique]
bonjour à tous très heureuse de vous
retrouver pour cette émission qui sera
largement consacrée à l'examen de la
réforme des retraites qui a débuté jeudi
au Sénat et qui va se poursuivre